SUBCOMMITTEE FOURTH THE
MINISTRATION THERE ARE NO ITEMS
IN THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR.
SINCE WE ONLY HAVE TWO MEMBERS
OF A QUORUM CELS FOR A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THE FIRST ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER -- ONE OFFICE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS CHAIR --
I AM PONDERING AB THIS TIME THE
CHIEF OF STAFF TO THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
I'LL MAKE MY PRESENTATION REFER
ALLOW FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
SO AS YOU KNOW THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT BUDGET
LAST DECADE.
WHILE THE DUTIES OF THE
GOVERNORS OF THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAVE REMAINED
THE SAME.
SO BEFORE YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION WE ARE REQUESTING
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND IN GENERAL
FUND AND A STAFFING INCREASE OF
FOUR POSITIONS.
BRINGING US TO A TOTAL OF TEN
POSITIONS TO SUPPORT LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR'S.
OFFICE IN FOR FILLING THE DUTIES
AND OBLIGATIONS OF THE OFFICE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
LL.
WE HAVE NO COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSAL FINANCE.
A NUMBER OF COMMENTS.
IN THE COMMISSION COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
CASEY NOTION IS BIG I KNOW IN
PAST YEARS YOU HAD A STAFF OF
THIRTY TO THIRTY DOWN THERE
THERE WERE THIRTY AND NOW YOU'RE
DOWN TO SEVEN YES.
YOURSELF THAT INCLUDES THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
SEVEN WELL I I KNOW THAT
GOVERNOR'S TEST WHICH IN THE
GOVERNOR OF A LOT MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND PREVIOUSLY
SO -- THIS IS SOMETHING I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM RIGHT NOW SO.
WE'LL GO AHEAD HOLD THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
OKAY MOVING ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM.
OTHER NUMBER -- TWO EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON A TEACHER BLOOM
WITH PART IN FINANCE -- SO OR
MAYBE BODIES -- EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT PROPOSAL OF WOULD
BASICALLY TAKE BUT WE WE HAD
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
HOW WHICH IS TO CREATE A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR CREDIT FOR EVERY
FAMILY WITH A CHILD UNDER -- SIX
INCREASE THE MAXIMUM EARNINGS --
FOR FOR IN INDEED INDIVIDUAL TO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE TAX CREDIT --
TO THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND TO CHANGE THE FACE UP
STRUCTURE OF THE CREDIT SO THAT --
PEOPLE AT THE UPPER END OF THE
OF THE CREDIT SCHEDULE.
WILL RECEIVE A MORE SUBSTANTIAL
CREDIT -- WHAT WE AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THE MAY REVISE WE ALL
ADMITTED THAT PROGRAM?
BY.
CHANGING INSTEAD OF A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR PER FAMILY CREDIT
INCREASING IT TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
ON THE PROPOSAL'S A HOLES
EXPECTED TO AFFECT THREE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS AND COST -- AT THIS.
US ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
IT IS -- COMBINED WITH A
CONFORMITY PACKAGE THATWOULD
PAY FOR THE OF THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION WE ARE PROPOSING A
NAME CHANGE.
TO THE TO THE CALIFORNIA E.
EIGHTY SEE A COST OF LIVING
REFUND.
LIKE I I MISS THE LESS THE COST
IS WHAT -- CAL CAL THE HC A COST
OF LIVING REFUND.
THAT'S AN AND NAME CHANGE
[inaudible]
L. L..
YEAH -- THE ONLY CHANGE AT THIS
PROPOSAL MAKES FROM THE PREVIOUS.
PROPOSAL THEY SUBMITTED IN
JANUARY WAS TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF THE THE CREDIT FOR
FILERS WITH IT FOR ELIGIBLE
FILERS WITH AT LEAST ONE
DEPENDENT.
UNDER THE AGE OF SIX FROM FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
WE THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COST ESTIMATES
FOR THIS PROPOSAL REASONABLE.
WHAT IS THE MINISTRATION WANT TO
RENAME THE EITC? TO THE ORDER.
ONE RESPONSE [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO SO WE THINK THAT THE THAT THE
CALL IN AT THE KELLY IDC ACOSTA
WE REFUNDED IT KEEPS THE NAME
DHC WITH PEOPLE FAMILIAR WITH.
BUT ALSO GIVES IT A A NAME THAT
SIGNIFIES THAT IT THAT IT'S
THERE TO HELP FAMILIES PAY FOR
THE THE HIGH COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA.
OKAY IN.
THE I. T. C. HELPS WITHOUT
SOMEWHAT.
YES AND AND WE THINK THAT THEY
HAVE ALSO BEEN REFINED ALICE
ACOSTA REBRAND THE PROGRAM.
HI SHOULDN'T COST ANYTHING.
WILL BE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TO PUT OUT -- MATERIALS NEW AT
NEW NAME THERE WILL BE
ADDITIONAL WORDS PUT IN THE EXIT
BUT THE THOSE MATERIALS ARE ARE
UPDATED EACH YEAR.
ND THEN THERE ARE CERTAINLY THE
THE PARAMETERS OF THE PROGRAM
WILL BE CHANGES ALSO ALL THAT
MATERIAL HAVE TO BE UPDATED IN
ANY CASE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
THIS WEEK'S THANK YOU.
I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT AND I
KNOW THAT IT'S A VERY IT.
WELL ONE OF BACKING THE MOST
EFFECTIVE TOOLS WE HAVE TO FIGHT
POVERTY -- IN THE STATE YOU KNOW
THE THE GOVERNOR'S -- PROPOSAL
HELLER HERE CONTINUES -- TO
EXCLUDE -- LOW INCOME IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES WHO -- FILE WITH AYE
TEN NUMBERS AND I KNOW WE
DISCUSSES THE LAST HEARING --
YOU KNOW I THINK INCLUDING THOSE
FAMILIES WOULD BENEFIT UP TO TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
CHILDREN -- AND IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND EXPANDING THESE
CREDITS -- I THINK WOULD BE VERY
VERY HELPFUL SOCIAL SAFETY NET --
FOR MANY COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE COMMUNITIES IN MY
DESTRUCTION AND OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE CAN USE DISCUSS WHY
THAT WAS AND TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
HERE WITH A MAY REVISE.
YEAH IT WAS REALLY A MATTER OF
PRIORITIES AND AND WITH LIMITED
RESOURCES WE HAVE TRYING TO
MAINTAIN BUDGET RESILIENCE --
THE THE FOCUS WAS REALLY I'M
TRYING TO GET AS MUCH MONEY AS
POSSIBLE OUT TO FAMILIES WITH
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN AND THAT WAS
CONSIDERED THAT WITH SO THE
INCREASING THE THE CREDIT FOR
FAMILIES WITH YOUNG CHILDREN
FROM FIVE HUNDRED TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS WAS CONSIDERED THE MOST
EFFECTIVE.
USE THAT MONEY.
I I MEAN I THINK THIS IS A
VULNERABLE FROM.
SOME OF THESE FOLKS ARE VERY
VULNERABLE NEED THE SOCIAL
SAFETY NET -- AND I WANT US TO
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN -- ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THOSE -- AT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WHO WHO NEED THE
SOCIAL SAFETY AND FRANKLY
DESERVE IT SO -- I'M COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY.
INCOME OF THE PUBLIC ON THIS.
SORRY GOOD AFTERNOON TURN.
I JUST THOUGHT.
THERE WE GO -- GOOD AFTERNOON
DEEP AND AGONY SO WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER -- WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE CAL YOU EIGHTY
C. EXPANSION BUT WOULD REQUEST
THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER
EXPANDING IT -- TO I TEN FATHERS
AS WELL -- I TEN FATHERS ARE
CONTRIBUTE JUST AS MUCH THEIR
LABOR IN TAXES IN THE STATE AND
YET ARE EXCLUDED ON JUST THE
FROM THIS REALLY CRITICAL.
I ANTI POVERTY MEASURE AND WE
THINK THAT AS WE EXPAND THE
CALLIE ATC I IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL FOR US TO ENSURE THAT
INVESTMENTS THAT CALIFORNIA IS
MAKING FOR ANTI POVERTY PROGRAMS
WORK FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND SO WE JUST REQUEST THAT I
TEN FATHER'S INCLUDING THE CAL
YOU EIGHTY C. PROGRAM AND
EXPANSION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
NIGHT AT LEAST ON THE LINE WITH
UNITED WAY SO CALIFORNIA I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT -- SO IT HAS
BEEN EXPRESSED THE MERITS OF THE
I. T. C. R. MANY THEY HELPED
FAMILIES PUT MONEY ON THE TABLE
THEY HELP OUR PARENTS GET THEIR
KIDS TO SCHOOL -- BUT WHY SHOULD
SOME OF THE FAMILIES FOR
CALIFORNIA PART TAKEN THIS AND
NOT OTHERS -- SO WHERE IS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BUT I ALSO FEEL THAT --
OF FAMILIES THAT HAVE CHILDREN
THAT ARE IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AND
ARE FALLING WITH THE NIGHT
INDEFINITELY YOU KNOW NEED TO BE
INCLUDED -- THE PRIMARILY
FAMILIES OF COLOR TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SIX THOUSAND WHO ARE
CHILDREN -- WHO ARE MISSING OUT
JUST BECAUSE THEIR THEIR PARENTS
ARE FILING WITH THE NIGHT -- TEN
THERE -- FINALLY THEIR TAXES
THEY CONTRIBUTE TO THE ECONOMY
SO -- WE WOULD URGE YOUR SONG
SUPPORT IN THIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR TERRY ONLY WITH
ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT ACTION
OF JUST ECHO MY COLLEAGUES -- OF
REALLY -- INSIGHTFUL COMMENTS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
INCLUDING AYE TENS OF THIS
PROPOSAL OTHERWISE WE'RE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S TRYING TO DO HERE AND
CAN'T SAY ENOUGH ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF YEAH I. T. C.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ALSO SUIT STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
AND WE ALSO -- SUPPORT AGREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE THE I TEN A
HOUSEHOLDS INCLUDED IN THIS
PROPOSAL IN PARTICULAR WE DO
WANT TO CALL OUT AND SUPPORT THE
TAX CONFORMITY PIECE WE THINK
GOING FORWARD.
THE WAY TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S PAID FOR
GOING FORWARD WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS SMART ON
THAT FRONT AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO APPROVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOES YOUR GROW WITH THE S. E. W.
I. CERTAIN STATES COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THANKS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND CHAIR --
MONEY WHICHEVER ROGERS AND I
WORK WITH THAT GOLDEN STATE
OPPORTUNITY FOUNDATION -- WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND APPLIED
BOTH -- THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO EXPAND THIS
IMPORTANT -- PARTY PROGRAM --
SPECIFICALLY I DO JUST WANT TO
CALL OUT THAT WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF DETECTION FOR ME
MEASURE PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS OF
WHAT'S THE SERVER JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF FURTHER EXPANDING THE
IDC IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO SOME MEMBERS
WICKS -- COMMENTS -- WE DO
ENCOURAGE THE INCLUSION OF
ITUNES IN THE PROPOSAL TO HELP
COVER LOW INCOME COMING IN
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES THANK YOU.
CHERRY MEMBERS MET THE CORPSMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION WE DO APPLY
THE GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS ON E. I.
T. C..
ARE THANKFUL TO THE DO OUT FOR
THEIR ON GOING DIALOGUE -- OUR
CONCERNS LIKE SPECIFICALLY IN
THE FEDERAL TAX CONFORMITY
PROPOSAL THERE ARE STILL A
NUMBER OF ITEMS -- SOME OF WHICH
CALIFORNIA TRADITIONALLY DOES
CONFORM TO THEIR LEAVING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON THE TABLE AND IN ADDITION
WE'RE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
WITH THE INCLUSION OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS PROPOSAL --
AS WELL AS ITS AMBIGUITY BOTH IN
THE LANGUAGE AND BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS RIGHT NOW -- IT'S VERY
VERY SIMILAR SO IT SEEMS TO THE
ENTERPRISE ZONE PROGRAM THAT WE
HAD IN CALIFORNIA AND OUR
CONCERN IS THAT IF WE MOVE
FORWARD -- PARTICULARLY WITHOUT
SOME SERIOUS GUARD RAILS ON THIS
PROGRAM WE COULD VERY MUCH AND
UP UNDERMINING THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE SEEKING TO SERVE
THROUGH THE E. I. T. C. PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
THE SERGEANTS CAN CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I LINK YES HE
WITH THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED EXPANSION OF
THE CALIFORNIA E. I. T. C. AND
WHAT ALIGN OURSELVES.
I'M WITH THE COMMENTS PREVIOUSLY
MADE AROUND SERVING -- ALL
ELIGIBLE WORKING CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES THANK YOU FOR YOU.
I'M KEVIN ENDS GO WITH THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
INTERFAITH COALITION.
AS THE COALITION OF FAITH BASED
GROUPS OUR PRIMARY FOCUS IS
ADDRESSING CHILDHOOD POVERTY SO
WE ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT.
OF THE EXPANSION OF CAL YEAH I.
T. C. AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
EXPANDING IT TO I TEN HOLDERS
THANK YOU.
REGINA BANKS OF THE LUTHERAN
OFFICE OF PUBLIC POLICY AND
EXPRESSION OF THE EVANGELICAL
LUTHERAN CHURCH IN AMERICA WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND WE WOULD
JUST LIKE TO REMIND YOU THAT I
TEN FIVE FILERS.
ARE VIBRANT PARTS OF OUR
CONGREGATIONS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WE WOULD URGE YOU TO
REMEMBER THEM IN YOUR
DELIBERATIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
EXPANSION OF THE EITC PROGRAM
AND WE SUPPORT THOSE EXPANSIONS
BUT AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
HAVE STATED WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF I TEN FILERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN NELSON
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES WE ALSO
APPLAUD -- THE GOVERNOR'S -- WE
BELIEVE PRUDENT STEPS -- TO THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN -- TO EXPAND ON
THE I. T. C. -- THAT WE'VE HAD
THE STATE -- LIFT -- LOW INCOME
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY WE THINK
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT STEP WE
WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND ACT ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUES
AND ALLIES -- ON THE INCLUSION
OF ITUNES FILERS WE BELIEVE
THESE FOLKS MAKE UP THE BACKBONE
OF MANY COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
THE WORK FORCE MANY COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE WE THINK IS FOR
THIS PRUDENT TO ENSURE THAT
FOLKS ARE PAYING TAXES GET -- A
BENEFIT -- WE WOULD -- ALSO --
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S TAX
CONFORMITY PROPOSAL -- BUT AS A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION WOULD ALSO --
ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF CONCERN
AROUND IDEA OF OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS -- WE'VE SEEN THAT PLAY OUT --
IN PREVIOUS YEARS AND NOT
NECESSARILY BE AS BENEFICIAL --
THE CALIFORNIANS -- BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S TAX
CONFORMITY PACKAGE US
CONSTRUCTED A DOES A GOOD JOB OF
GENERATING REVENUE AND NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT THE EITC IS NOT
LINKED -- TO THE GENERAL FUND --
IN OUT YEARS -- IN JUST AS AN
ASIDE -- IN FUTURE YEARS WE
WOULD IMPLORE THIS COMMITTEE ON
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE INCLUSION.
OF FAMILY HOME CARE PROVIDERS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY EXCLUDED FROM
OUR RECEIVING A BENEFIT TO THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THE WORK THAT THESE
FOLKS TO CENTRAL TO ASSURING
THAT FOLKS CAN GET.
A SERVICES IN THEIR HOMES -- AND
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND ARE
INSTITUTIONALIZE A WE BELIEVE
THIS OF OF VALUE -- AND THINK
THAT -- THEY SHOULD BE REWARDED
FOR THE WORK THAT THEY PROVIDE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI ESPERANZA GIVE HONOR WITH
CHIRLA WE JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND WOULD LIKE FOR THE
EXPANSION OF THE STATE CREDIT TO
INCLUDE IMMIGRANTS WHO FILE
TAXES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE HOLES AUTUMN OPEN ONE OUR
NEXT ITEM -- ET I SEE ADVANCE
PAYMENTS -- SO IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE MORE EFFECTIVE
ASSISTANCE TO FAMILIES WHO
QUALIFY FOR THE KELLY AT SEE
COST OF LIVING REFUND.
THE MAY REVISE POSES TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
ESTABLISH A PROGRAM FOR
PROVIDING ADVANCE EITC PAYMENTS
TO FAMILIES WHO QUALIFY.
MANY ADVOCATE FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES HAVE RECOMMENDED MOVING
TO MONTHLY PAYMENTS FOR YOU
EIGHTY C. AS WE'D BETTER.
HELP FAMILIES MEET ENDS MEET.
INSTEAD OF WAITING ALL YEAR TO
RECEIVE THEIR EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT AT AT THE END OF THE YEAR
AT TAX TIME FAMILIES WOULD
RECEIVE DISTRIBUTIONS THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR.
RAISING THEIR INCOME EVERY MONTH
SINCE MOVING -- THE INCOME BALTO.
SO WHAT THE MAY REVISED POSES IS
THAT FRANCHISE TAX WILL DEVELOP
A SYSTEM. FOR PROVIDING ADVANCE
PAYMENTS TO CERTAIN CAL THE ADC
RECIPIENTS.
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE OPEN TO ANY
HELP HOUSEHOLD THAT HAS FILED A
RETURN -- FILED AT LEAST ONE
RETURN WITH THE FTV IN THE PRIOR
FIVE YEARS AND HIS INCOME AND
INCOME CIRCUMSTANCES.
I'M SORRY HOUSEHOLD INCOME
CIRCUMSTANCES.
ARE SUCH THAT THEY EXPECT TO
RECEIVE A CAL THE ATC OF AT
LEAST TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
THE CURRENT YEAR -- SO THE WAY
THAT THE MONTHLY PAYMENT WOULD
WORK IS THAT -- IF IF YOU
QUALIFY FOR LET'S SAY A TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR CREDIT.
YOU WOULD -- WE WOULD HAVE TO BE
WOULD CUT THAT AMOUNT AND HALF.
HELP FOR RESULT GO IN TWO
MINUTES AND THEN DIVIDE THAT
OVER THE REMAINING MONTHS OF THE
YEAR SO IF YOU'VE GOT TWELVE
MONTHS LEFT.
IN THE YEAR.
ARE THE TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
WOULD BE CUT DOWN SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND THEN TO BE. FIFTY
TWELVE FIFTY DOLLAR PAYMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
I'M.
THE REASON THAT THAT IT WOULD BE
CUT IN HALF IS THAT THERE'S A
REAL CONCERN.
THAT IN RECEIVING ADVANCE
PAYMENTS IT'S DIFFICULT TO
PREDICT PRECISELY WHICH EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT IS GOING TO BE.
AND SO WE WANT TO AVOID AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE.
HOUSEHOLDS GETTING ADVANCEMENTS
THAT EXCEED THE AMOUNT OF THE A
TO SEE THAT THE ACTUALLY EARN
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR -- AND SO
WITH YOUR BY CUTTING FIVE
LIMITED IT ONLY GETTING HALF OF
THEIR EXPECTED THE IDC.
THANK THE GREATLY REDUCES THE
THE POSSIBILITY OF OVERPAYMENT.
AS IF THEY ARE OVER PAID THAT
HAVE TO BE WILL WILL HAVE.
TO TRY TO CUT TRY DO THAT THE
MONEY WILL THEN BE OWED WHEN
THEY FILED THEIR TAX RETURN THAT
COULD CAUSE A BURDEN ON THE ON
THE HOUSEHOLDS [inaudible]
COME.
THERE IS THERE HAS BEEN SOME
QUESTION RAISED ABOUT -- WHETHER.
RECEIPT OF THESE MONTHLY
PAYMENTS AS OPPOSED TO RECEIVING
OF THE AGENCY AT THE END OF YOUR
MIGHT.
IMPACT SOME FEDERAL -- THE
RECEIPT THE RECEIPT OF SOME
FEDERAL PROGRAMS -- PARTICULAR
CAL FRESH AND HAD SECTION.
EIGHT HOUSING ASSISTANCE -- AND
AS WELL AS OTHER PROGRAMS SO --
IN THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AT
THAT -- WILL BE AVAILABLE
SHORTLY -- WE WERE WE HAVE -- WE
MAKE ANY ANY WORK TO DO THIS
ADVANCE PAYMENT CONTINGENT UPON.
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
CERTIFYING THAT -- THAT THERE
WILL BE NO IMPACT SO THAT MOST
LIKELY WILL MEAN GETTING WAIVERS
FROM FEDERAL AGENCIES -- AND
WE'RE LOOKING INTO THAT THAT IS
GOING TO TAKE OF A FEW MONTHS AT
LEAST -- EVEN WITHOUT ONCE ONCE
HAVE TO BE HAS BEEN GIVEN --
CLEARANCE ESSENTIALLY THAT THAT
THIS WILL NOT AFFECT RECEIPT OF
OTHER FEDERAL PROGRAM DOLLARS --
IT WILL TAKE ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MONTHS FOR IT TO BE TO GET THE
SYSTEMS UP AND RUNNING.
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE -- THE THE
ADVANCE PAYMENT SO.
THE EARLIEST WE WOULD EXPECT TO
BE PROVIDING ADVANCE PAYMENTS TO
BE SOMETIME IN EARLY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY REPOSITORY CELLS QUORUM
RIGHT NOW.
THE LOCAL POLICE.
FIRE HERE. TO LACKEY.
NAZARIAN WICKS.
THERE WERE TO MOVE BACK TO ISSUE
NUMBER -- ONE RECOGNITIONS DOT
THE SPRING FISCAL LETTER --
IZZARD MOTION
CAN GO TO MOTIONS SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE COOPER HI TO LACKEY
[inaudible]
SYRIAN BRICKS.
THEY WILL CONTINUE NOW THE L. L..
BRAIN WHETHER FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
IN ORDER -- IN REVIEWING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- FOR PRESS
APPROACH TO PROVIDING MONTHLY
PAYMENTS WE NOTED THAT THE
PROPOSED APPLICATION PROCESS
INVOLVES REQUIRING -- FILERS TO
FIRST REGISTER WITH THE MY F. T.
P. INTERNET APPLICATION -- IT
THIS IS A A REASONABLE APPROACH
IN TERMS OF ESTABLISHING -- THE
THE FILERS IDENTITY IN VERIFYING
THE ADDRESS HOWEVER WE KNOW IT'S
A IT'S A FAIRLY COMPLICATED TO
PART PROCESS THAT CAN TAKE --
ANYWHERE FROM -- A ONE TO TWO
ONE TO THREE WEEKS TO COMPLETE
AND AND THEN THE FILER WOULD BE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR A A MONTHLY
PAYMENT AT THAT TIME.
AND SO THERE'S A THREE AT LEAST
A THREE STEP PROCESS REQUIRED.
TO APPLY IN AND IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS MIGHT BE DIFFICULT FOR
VOTERS WHO WERE -- SEEKING
ASSISTANCE AND AND AND AND
RECEIVING MONTHLY PAYMENTS AND
WE WE WE JUST ON THINK THAT
THERE MAY BE TIME. TO STEP BACK
AND AND THINK ABOUT HOW ELSE WE
MIGHT DESIGNED THIS PROGRAM SO
THAT IT'S THAT IS DESIGNED IN A
WAY THAT IS -- USER FRIENDLY AND
AND AND STILL PROTECTS AGAINST --
OVERPAYMENTS -- TO TO TO FILERS
SO WE THINK THAT YOU HAVE TIME --
IT.
IT DURING THE PROCESS AS
DEPARTMENT FINANCE MENTIONED
SEEKING THESE WAIVERS AND AND
THEN IF THE WAIVERS ARE RECEIVED
QUICKLY YOU CAN -- PERHAPS IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROVIDE --
SOME FUNDING TO FTP CONTINGENT
ON RECEIVING THOSE WAIVERS --
AND THEN REVISITING THIS IN
JANUARY ON ON WHETHER THIS IS
THE BEST APPROACH GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ALTHOUGH AN OPEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- TERRY OLD
FROM ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION I GUESS I'VE THREE
COMMENTS -- FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO JUST APPLY THE GOVERNOR AND
THE STAFF -- FOR BEING
INNOVATIVE ABOUT MOVING TOWARD
MONTHLY AND ADVANCE PAYMENTS
WITH THE ATC THIS IS A REALLY
GREAT WAY TO MAKE THESE.
THE THIS CREDIT EVEN MORE USEFUL
IN PEOPLE'S LIVES SMOOTHING OUT
INCOME VOLATILITY AND HELPING --
PEOPLE MEET THEIR BUDGET ON A
MONTHLY BASIS WE THINK IT'S
REALLY FANTASTIC IT WOULD PUT
CALIFORNIA HAS OF THE GAME IN
THE REST THE COUNTRY -- SECOND
ALL I REALLY ENCOURAGE.
YOU ALL TO PUT A STAKE IN THE
GROUND ON STARTING DOWN THE ROAD
OF IMPLEMENTING RECOGNIZING THAT
IT WILL TAKE TIME.
AND RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE WORKED
OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S AS
USER FRIENDLY AS YOU SAY AND AS
AND DOESN'T CAUSE HARDSHIP FOR
EITHER THE FILERS OR FOR THE
STATE -- BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
PUTTING A STAKE IN THE GROUND
AND STARTING DOWN THAT PATH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND WE SHOULD
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT MOMENTUM.
AND FINALLY I THINK WE SHOULD
TAKE TIME TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST
WAY -- TO IMPLEMENT THIS PROCESS
AND ENGAGE WITH EXPERTS ON USER
EXPERIENCE EXPERTS -- WITH
AFFECTED GROUPS SO THAT WE CAN --
FIND THE BEST WAY TO TO MAKE
THIS IS FRICTIONLESS AS POSSIBLE
OF FOR THE APPLICANTS BECAUSE
WITH THE LAST THING ON EARTH WE
WANT TO DO IS CREATE A GREAT
PROGRAM THAT NO ONE CAN.
NO ONE CAN ACCESS.
AND THEN FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY I NEGLECTED FROM MY PREVIOUS
COMMENTS ON THE PREVIOUS MATTER
WHICH IS THAT I AM ALSO IN IN
FAVOR OF THE CONFORMITY --
ASPECTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL MIGHT FORGOT TO SAY
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
WELL MISTER CHAIR MY CAROL AGAIN
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO DO ADVANCE PAYMENTS
WE THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
AMERICA THIS WEEK CONCURRENT
MUCH OF WHAT MISS ALL THE JUST
HAD TO SAY WE WOULD RAISE JUST A
COUPLE OF ADDITIONAL POINTS ONE
AS WE AGREE WITH THE LA OWES
ANALYSIS.
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL CUMBERSOME
THIS OF THE CURRENT PROPOSAL BY
ON THE BY THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THIS AND WE WOULD URGE THE AT
THAT APARTMENT.
TO PERHAPS TAKE A LOOK AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN STREAMLINE THIS AND
MAKE THIS A A SIMPLER PROCESS
MORE ONE STEP APPROACH THAN THE
CURRENT APPROACH -- SECOND -- WE
IT'S NOT OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE NEED A WAIVER FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR THESE
PURPOSES THAT.
KATAKANA TAKES A LEGAL --
STANDARD THAT I THINK WHAT WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING FOR IS A
CLARIFICATION AND I THINK THERE
BE OTHER STATES WILL BE SEEKING
THE SAME CLARIFICATION AND I
WANT TO UNDERSCORE HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS BECAUSE WE CERTAINLY DO
NOT.
WANT TO JEOPARDIZE PEOPLE'S
CALPERS BENEFITS ARE MEDI CAL
BENEFITS THEY'RE SECTION.
EIGHT AND AND THEN LASTLY I DO
WANT TO ALSO FLAG AND BRING INTO
CONSIDERATION THAT WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL AND THE DEPARTMENT
MENTION THIS -- THAT WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
WE HAVE A LOT OF OVER PAYMENTS
WERE REDO ADVENT WE HAVE ADVANCE
PAYMENTS.
ON THE LAST THING WE WANT FOR
OUR FOR OUR LOW INCOME CLIENTS
TO HAVE HIS START GETTING TAX
LIENS AND NOTICES FROM FTP THAT
THEY OWE MONEY.
SO WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT A
REALLY DO THIS SMART AND
CAREFULLY AND WHILE WE WANT TO
GET AS MUCH MONEY AS WE CAN AND
WORK POINT STANCE WE DON'T WANT
TO GET TOO MUCH MONEY IN HER
CLIENT SANDS.
SO THAT I WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE
WE GO FORWARD IN CONSIDER THIS --
I GUESS I AGREE WE DO NEED TO
GET THE IT DEPARTMENT THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THIS BUT I ALSO
THINK WE NEED TO TAKE IT SLOW
AND CAREFUL THANK YOU.
BUT YOU.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE AGAIN WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION I JUST WANTED TO
ECHO SOME OF MR HERALD COMMENTS
AROUND THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING THAT WE SECURE WHATEVER.
APPROVALS WE NEED -- FOR SUCH
THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE THIS
INCOME IS NOT COUNTED -- AGAINST
THESE FAMILIES -- FOR OTHER
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAMS WE
DON'T WANNA DISADVANTAGED THE
SAME FAMILIES IN THEIR
ELIGIBILITY FOR THOSE CRITICAL
SUPPORTS AS WELL THANK YOU.
FOLLOWING UP ON THE WAY THE
QUESTION IS DO AS IT DEAL HAVE
HAD TIME TO TALK TO VERY
STAKEHOLDERS.
WILL BE IMPACTED.
I WE'VE TALKED MANY STAKEHOLDER
SINCE PROCESS YES AND MOODY'S
STAKEHOLDERS REPRESENTING PEOPLE
WOULD BE AFFECTED.
MORE SOULS COMMENTS -- THERE
WERE SOME COMMENTS WELL THERE
THERE WERE COMMENTS WERE
GENERALLY FAVORABLE TOWARDS US
ARE SOME COMMENTS ARE SUGGESTING.
ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS A DEFERRED
PAYMENTS -- WHICH IS WHERE.
RATHER THAN PAYING THE THE EHC
IN ADVANCE YOU WOULD WAIT.
TILL THEY FILED A RETURN IN AND
YOU SAY OKAY YOU ARMED TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS WILL PAY A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH FOR THE
NEXT. TWELVE MONTHS -- THERE
CERTAINLY ARE SOME ADVANTAGE TO
THAT NOT CLEAR.
WHETHER WHETHER PEOPLE WOULD BE%
INTERESTED IN IN GETTING THAT --
SO I'LL BE OTHER VARIETY OF
COMMENTS.
AS FAR AS THE CHAINS GO TO THE
I. T. C. PROGRAM HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION TO OUT REACH TO
COMMUNICATE THESE CHANGES. TO
THE PUBLIC I I HAVE NOT FULLY
THOUGHT THROUGH HOW HOW WE WOULD
COMMUNICATE CLEARLY WITH WE
WOULD NEED TO TO DO SOME
COMMUNICATION THOUGH TO LET
OTHER PEOPLE KNOW THIS NEW
PROGRAM IS AVAILABLE.
WHEN YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT IS
Q. CIRCLE BACK WITH STAFF PLEASE?
CERTAINLY OKAY -- IS IN THE
BLUEPRINT SUPPORTIVE OF AN
ADVANCE PAYMENT MY CONCERN IS
THAT WE TAKE THE TIME TO CRAPPIE
THOUGHTFUL ADVANCE PAYMENT
MECHANISM.
IT LOOKS LIKE WITH TIME SINCE
THE STATE STILL NEED TO GO TO
THE WAIVER PROCESS.
SO WHEN ALL THIS ITEM OPEN.
I'M SORRY.
MR.
TO JUST WANNA SAY -- ONE ECHO
WHAT THE TERM JUST SAID AND I
THINK WE ALL SUPPORT THE IDEA
MONTH ADVANCE PAYMENT BUT THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
RAISED BY STAFF.
I THINK ARE ONES THAT WE'RE ALL
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WE WANT TO
DO IT BUT WE WANT TO GET IT DONE
RIGHT -- I'M NOT SURE IF THE
FIRST QUESTION WAS ASKED OF IF
YOU IF YOU KNOW HOW LONG THE
FEDERAL WAIVERS GOING TO TAKE.
WE DON'T WE DON'T KNOW
SPECIFICALLY -- YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN TOLD THAT IT HE COULD BE
THREE MONTHS OR MORE SO OKAY AND
I'M ASSUMING THAT TIME WE HAVE
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND AND FIGURE OUT
THE RIGHT DETAILS ON THIS.
THAT THAT'S TRUE I WILL SAY
THOUGH THAT IT NEEDS TO BE PART
OF THE BUDGET IF WE'RE GOING TO
GET STARTED ON DOING ANYTHING
THIS FISCAL YEAR SO.
OKAY WELL AGAIN WITH AND AGAIN
ECHOING WHEN THE CONCERNS I
THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
PUBLIC ON THIS -- WANNA MAKE
SURE PARTICULAR WHERE ADDRESSING --
IN THE CONCERNS AROUND -- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MONTHLY
BENEFITS AND AND AND MAKE SURE
WE GET THIS DONE RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR OF RESULTS.
RIGHT SO -- SORT ARE MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL WHICH IT'S PART OF OUR
IT WAS ALSO -- IN OUR GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL -- ALEX COMBINED
WITH THE CONFORMITY PACKAGE IN
THE EIGHTY SI PACKAGE.
WOULD PROVIDE TAX BREAKS WOULD
CONFORM TO FEDERAL TAX BREAKS
FOR INVESTMENT.
IN CALL FOR CALIFORNIA
OPPORTUNITIES OWN PROJECTS --
TAX CUTS AND JOBS ACT FEDERAL
TAX IN JOBS I CAN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CREATED OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS.
ALL STATES WERE ALLOWED TO
DESIGNATE OPPORTUNITIES OWNS IN
CERTAIN LOW INCOME AREAS.
AND CALIFORNIA'S PARTICIPATE IN
THAT PROCESS AND DESIGNATED --
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE
OPPORTUNITIES HOMES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
INVESTMENT IS ENCOURAGED BY
SEVERAL CENTERS AND I'M NOT
GOING TO GO INTO NOW OF HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ON WHAT THOSE
INCENTIVES ARE BUT THEIR
SUBSTANTIAL INCENTIVES FOR
PEOPLE TO INVEST IN THESE.
ZONES.
WE ARE PROPOSING AND MAY RISE
MAY REVISED TO CONFORM TO THESE
TAX INCENTIVES. FOR INVESTMENT
INOPPORTUNE SO THAT ARE DIRECTED
PROJECTS THAT ARE BOTH WITHIN
CALIFORNIA OPPORTUNITIES OWNS SO
LIMITED TO CALIFORNIA.
AND ARE OF OF QUALIFY TYPE OF
INVESTMENT AND THE QUALIFY TYPES
INVESTMENT.
WOULD BE INVESTMENT THAT FOCUS
ON LOW INCOME HOUSING.
AND THAT FOCUS ON GREEN ENERGY --
WE ALSO -- ARE PUTTING.
ON A CAP ON THE AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT THEY CAN GO INTO
THESE STONES SO THAT -- I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CONCERN
RAISED ABOUT POTENTIAL OPEN
ENDED REVENUE LOSSES AND SO --
WE WILL HAVE A CAP ON THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY GOING INTO THE INTO THE
ZONE SO THAT THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE LOSSES IS CAPPED.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ARE GOING TO MORE
DETAIL ON ON THE U. L. L..
THANK YOU WE HAVE A FEW CONCERNS --
WITH THE WITH THE PROPOSAL FIRST --
RESEARCH ON PAST PROGRAM SIMILAR
TO OPPORTUNITIES OWNS OF FOUND
MIXED EVIDENCE ABOUT THEIR
WHETHER OR NOT THEY BRING
POSITIVE ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO
THE RESIDENTS OF THE TARGETED
COMMUNITIES AND BECAUSE OF THAT.
WE THINK THERE'S A FAIR AMOUNT
OF UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT RESIDENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS WILL RECEIVE
POSITIVE ECONOMIC BENEFITS FROM
THE PROGRAM -- SECONDLY IF
CALIFORNIA WHERE DOES CREATE A
STATE OPPORTUNITIES DON'T
BENEFIT -- WE THINK AT THAT
THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE THAT A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE TAX
BENEFIT.
A WOULD GO NOT TO INVESTORS THAT
ARE -- BRINGING NEW INVESTMENT
SHIFTING IT FROM OTHER STATES
BUT INSTEAD OF PROVIDING BENEFIT --
TO INVESTORS WHO WOULD HAVE
INVESTED IN CALIFORNIA ANYWAY
SIMPLY IN RESPONSE TO THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM.
AND FINALLY WE HAVE CONCERNS
THAT OPPORTUNITIES OWNS A
PROBABLY AREN'T THE BEST
MECHANISM FOR FUNDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- WE THINK OF THAT THE
STATE'S HAS SEVERAL EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PROBABLY
BETTER THAN OPPORTUNITIES OWNS
FOR PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE RECOMMEND NOT
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
DOES THE MINISTER SHOULD HAVE AN
IDEA ON THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WILL BE AVAILABLE. FOR
THE TROUBLE I'M SORRY -- WE'RE
SHOOTING FOR LATER THIS WEEK.
THERE THIS WEEK YEAH.
OKAY QUESTION COMMITTEE.
MISTER IS THERE A GOD.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF FEW
THINGS FIRST OF ALL --
INTERESTED TO REVISIT WITH THE
LA -- WAS SAYING AS WELL BECAUSE
I THINK OF BETTER OVERSIGHT WILL
PROBABLY HELP -- OVERCOME SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE HAD
IN THE PAST.
WITH A WITH A WITH OTHER
PROGRAMS SIMILAR PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAD IN PLACE -- SO BE
INTERESTED TO SEE IF OVERSIGHT
COULD BE A BETTER COMPONENT
ADDED COMPONENT TO THIS SO THAT --
WE CAN GO FORWARD WITH THE
PROPOSAL -- BUT ALSO KNOW HOW WE
CAN HOLD IT ACCOUNTABLE --
THROUGH THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS AS WELL AS TO AN
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE -- BUT WHAT
IS THE ADMINISTRATION I HAD A
QUICK QUESTION ABOUT THE I GUESS
THAT THE FORM OF HOW YOU MOVE
FORWARD.
OF WHITE WHAT IS THE
MINISTRATION PREFER TAX BREAKS.
THROUGH TAX CONFORMITY INSTEAD
OF SOMETHING MORE EASILY
MEASURED AND UP.
LIKE A TAX CREDIT.
THAT WE CAN POTENTIALLY BE
OFFERING SO THAT IT WOULD ALSO
GIVE US SOME LEVEL OF
FLEXIBILITY.
YEAH I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS IS DO SOMETHING THAT'S
SIMILAR TO WHAT -- WHAT'S BEEN
DONE IN FEDERAL LEVEL SO THAT SO
THAT IT IT'S EASY FOR TAXPAYERS
IF THEY'RE ATTRACTED TO WE'RE
TRYING TO LEVERAGE THE FEDERAL
TAX BREAKS AND SO WE WANT TO
HAVE A TAX BREAKS THAT ARE
COMPARABLE. TO WHAT THEY'RE
PROVIDED SO THAT YOU KNOW THAT.
IF YOU'RE GETTING THESE THESE
TAX BREAKS FEDERAL OVER THAT
YOU'RE GETTING THE SAME ONES FOR
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK I THINK YEAH YOU COULD
OFFER A CREDIT AS AN ALTERNATIVE
AND I BUT I THINK WE FIGURED
SOMEBODY'S NEVER BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF YES YEAH.
YOU WOULD STILL BE ABLE TO
BETTER BUT WITH THESE -- TAX
BREAKS IT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
PEOPLE INVESTORS ARE GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON THE FEDERAL TAX
BREAKS AND SO THE BEGINNING THE
SAME THING FOR CALIFORNIA C.
COULD BE MORE ATTRACTIVE.
TO INVESTORS TOO MANY THAT WE
ARE ON A ON A PER DOLLAR BASIS.
HAVE WE HAVE HAVE WE TALK TO
FOLKS IN THE HOUSING INDUSTRY TO
SEE WHAT ROUTE THEY WOULD.
PREFER OR HOW WHAT WOULD WORK
BETTER.
IF I HOUSING IS A COMPONENT IN
THIS THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT I
HAVE NOT [inaudible]
OKAY -- HAS THERE BEEN ANY
DETAILS THAT.
HAS BEEN HAVE BEEN RELEASED ON
THIS THAT -- WE MAY HAVE NOT HAD
A CHANCE TO REVIEW OR SEE
[inaudible]
THERE'S AS FAR AS THE TRAILER
BILL I MEAN I HAVE I'M NOT SURE
I I'VE.
A JUST SOME THOUGHTS ON WHERE
WHERE THIS IS GOING.
IN IN THE IN PARTICULAR I I
COULD I CAN GIVE YOU WHATEVER
DETAILS I HAVE.
WELL JUST THE GENERAL GUIDELINES
OF WHAT THIS IS GONNA LOOK LIKE
HOW.
THE HOW WE WANT TO IMPLEMENT.
WELL IT WOULD BE -- WE WENT OVER
HOLDING THE ITEM OPEN BUT I'M
JUST TRYING TO SEE IF.
THERE'S ANY FURTHER THOUGHTS
THAT YOU CAN OFFER -- FOR AT
LEAST FOR TODAY -- IT WILL BE A
TAX BENEFIT THE LOOKS LIKE THE
FEDERAL TAX BENEFIT IN TERMS OF
GETTING THE DFERRAL AND THE
BASIS ADJUSTMENT -- IF IF YOU
HOLD ON FOR A CERTAIN TIME AND
THEN GETTING -- HE AN EXEMPTION
FROM CAPITAL GAINS TAXES FOR IN
EARNINGS INSIDE THE FUND -- IT
WILL BE LIMITED AS AS I SAID --
TO ARE PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA --
FEE THE FUND WILL THE FUND WILL
HAVE TO BE A 1100% CALIFORNIA.
OF FUND -- IT WILL BE IF YOU'LL
BE TAKING THE PORTION OF IT THE
TO CALIFORNIA BUT IF THE FUND
MUST BE DEDICATED TO CALIFORNIA --
AND FOR FOR THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING -- WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IS IS -- BASICALLY THE SAME
RULES.
THAT WOULD APPLY TO THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT OF THE
THERE THERE HAVE TO BE 20% OF
THE UNITS.
A MEETING -- HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
OVER 50% OF AREA -- MEDIAN
INCOME OR 40%.
OF THE UNITS -- OF HOUSING
PEOPLE WITH UNDER 6% SO THE SAME
RULES I DON'T KNOW -- SAME RULES
WE HAVE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT SO I'M I'M NOT SURE WHAT
ALL DETAILS YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
BUT THOSE ARE SOME OF THEM.
AND AND EACH TRAILER BILL SHE'LL
BE OUT SHOULD BE OUT SOON AND
AND THAT WILL GIVE YOU A LOT OF
DETAIL.
MR.
TO WANNA JUST BUILT ON THE
QUESTIONS NOW FROM OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM FROM LA -- YOU SAID THAT
THE REASON TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS TAX BREAK IS TO COME INTO
CONFORMITY WITH -- THE FEDERAL --
TAX PROPOSAL THAT THE FEDERAL
TAX LAW THAT -- THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS HAS MOVED
THROUGH.
BUT YOU ALSO MENTION THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT WHICH
HAS BEEN A PROVEN TAX CREDIT.
WHICH IS -- A FEDERAL TAX CREDIT
AND WE HAVE A STATE.
COUNTERPART TO THAT -- AND
THERE'S BEEN A DISCUSSION FOR
YEARS ABOUT EXPANDING THAT TAX
CREDIT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
LEVERAGING FEDERAL AND STATE TAX
DOLLARS TO DO WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
THAT PROGRAM IS MEASURED IT'S
CAPPED IT'S PROVEN.
AND TO MR NEWS ARIENS QUESTION
OF WHERE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WORLD HAS BEEN -- THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COMMUNITY HAS ASKED US
IN THE LEGISLATURE TO EXPAND THE
TAX CREDIT BUT THEY'VE NOT ASKED
US. TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
CONFORMITY AROUND OPPORTUNITY
SOUNDS I WILL SAY THE
OPPORTUNITIES ON CONVERSATION
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING IT'S NEW.
OR TRY TO WRAP OUR BRAINS AROUND
IT BUT IF YOU'RE ASKING US TO
DECIDE ON A TAX BREAK THAT.
WE'RE NOT SURE HOW IT'S GONNA
WORK.
VERSUS SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW IS
TESTED THAT IS WORKING IN OUR
LOCAL AND STATEWIDE MARKETS.
AGAIN EASY MEASURED AND CAPPED.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S PRETTY EASY
CALL SO AND AND AND THE GOVERNOR --
HAS PUBLICLY STATED HIS
COMMITMENT TO AN EXPANSION
BEFORE BY HOUSING TAX CREDIT IS
YOU KNOW THIS YEAR IN THE BUDGET
HE PUT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EXPANSION.
BUT JUST ONE YEAR NOT A MULTI
YEAR -- INCREASE AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT BEFORE WILL HOUSING
MARKETS WOULD REACT MUCH BETTER
TO KNOWING THAT THERE'S ONGOING
FUNDING SO GIVEN ALL THAT.
HOW IS IT THAT YOU?
DECIDED THAT YOU WANT TO GO WITH
THE ONGOING TAX BREAK AS OPPOSED
TO AN ONGOING MEASUREABLE CAPS.
TESTED TAX CREDIT.
BY THE ONGOING TAX RATE YOU MEAN
THE OPPORTUNITIES OWN CORRECT
WHICH WHICH WILL BE SOMEWHAT
LIMITED THAT WE EXPECT MOST THAT
INVESTMENT TO OCCUR IN THE IN
THE FIRST COUPLE OF YEARS -- BUT
ESSENTIALLY WE'RE WE'RE ADEQUATE
SO COST US.
YEAH THE THE COST WILL BE PART
IN THE SHORT TERM AND THEN AGAIN
IN THE AND THE LONG TERM THAT'S
RIGHT -- WEARS A TAX CREDIT WE
KNOW WHAT WE'RE SPENDING EVERY
YEAR AND IF WE NEEDED TO
DEPENDING ON THE ECONOMY IN A
AND BUDGET PICTURES RATCHET UP
RATCHET DOWN IF WE NEED.
TO WITH WHAT WAS SOME LIKE YES
WHERE IS IF WE VOTE ON THIS TAX
BREAK.
LITTLE UNCLEAR HOW THAT GETS
CAPPED WELL IT'S CAPTAIN THE IN
THE AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT THEY
CAN BE PUT INTO THE FUNDS IS
CAPPED.
COURSE ARE STILL WAITING FOR
LANGUAGE FOR THAT SO I DON'T
REALLY KNOW BUT I I GUESS MY
BROADER QUESTION IS AN INTEREST
BUILDING ON MISTER HIS ERRANT'S
POINT.
IS.
DO YOU SEE OPPORTUNITIES OUT AS
A BETTER MEANS OF INVESTING IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT THAN.
EXPANDING THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TAX CREDIT WHICH THE STATEWIDE
HOUSING COMMUNITY.
THINKS IS THE BETTER THING TO DO
JUST WANNA YEAH I KNOW THIS IS
LESLIE Là THIS IS NOT A A FOR
ONE OR THE OTHER THIS IS THIS IS
AN INTENTIONAL -- INCENTIVE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
EVEN THOUGH AT THIS MOMENT
THERE'S NOT A COMMITMENT FOR A
MULTI YEAR COMMITMENT TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX CREDIT
STATE.
YES SO IT IS A CHOICE FOR MAKING
LONG TERM -- I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THAT OKAY I I I JUST WANT TO SAY
I OBVIOUSLY I STILL HAVE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS AND IF
WE GET TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT.
MOVES IN THE DIRECTION I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO GO -- I'M NOT
SURE I'M GONNA BE I AND I HAVE
BEEN IN A A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
EXPANDING THE FOR WHILE THE TAX
CREDIT WHICH IS WHAT STATEWIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN ASKING FOR
FOR YEARS SO JUST WANNA PUT THAT
OUT THERE HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH.
YOUR APARTMENT AND OTHERS ON
THIS TOPIC BUT THE FOR A HOUSING
TAX CREDIT HAS BEEN SUPPORTED ON
A STRONG BIPARTISAN BASIS IN
THIS HOUSE -- AND I THINK THE
CASE STILL NEEDS TO BE MADE ON
OPPORTUNITIES US AGAIN
INTERESTING.
OPEN TO IT BUT WE REALLY NEED TO
SEE MORE INFORMATION.
CERTAINLY THANKS PRETTY SOON --
GOING UP A PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
YES.
MR YOUR CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON
BEHALF LIKE THIS ONE YES ON THE
HAVE A CAL O. Z. WE DO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ALTHOUGH
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT WE
WOULD SEEK THE FIRST IS AN
EXPANSION BEYOND -- CLEAN TECH
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING A TO
FULLER CONFORMITY AND ALSO ON
THE FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT CONTAIN
A NUMBER OF METRICS AND OTHER
PROVISIONS OF TRANSPARENCY WHICH
WE WOULD URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADOPT AS WELL.
WHILE WORKING WITH SENATOR
HERTZBERG ON HIS SB -- THREE
FIFTEEN THAT MIGHT GO ALONG
THOSE WAYS SO WITH THAT WE URGE --
YOUR ADOPTION OF THE FULLER
CONFORMITY PACKAGE THANK YOU YOU.
HI MISTER SHERMAN MEMBERS FOR
CHILLED WITH CALIFORNIA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC SUMMIT WHAT
WE WANT TO SUPPORT THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU JUST HAD
WITH CALLUM SEE MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THAT THERE'S A SENSE THAT WE
HAVE ABOUT OUR SKEPTICISM ABOUT
THIS AND MUCH OF THAT.
IS BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
ENTERPRISE ZONES AND I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT THIS KIND OF
INVESTMENT.
OF A POTENTIAL FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IS FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT THAN THE WAY IN WHICH
THE ENTERPRISE ZONE MODEL WORKED.
SO DON'T RELY ON OUR GOOD
FRIENDS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S TO LOOKED AT THE
ENTERPRISE ZONES MANY OF US DID
AND SAID THAT THING DIDN'T WORK
PROPERLY THIS ONE WORKS MUCH
DIFFERENTLY.
AND THE REASON THAT IT DOES IS
IT RELIES ON THE ABILITY OF A
PRIVATE INVESTOR. TO PUT MONEY
INTO A PROJECT THAT HAS A
COMMUNITY BENEFIT OR THE
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN BASICALLY
UNDER FINANCED.
THAT CAN GO ALONG WITH MATCHING
STATE.
FUNDS PARTICULARLY FOR HOUSING
FOR THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT.
BECAUSE INEVITABLY THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUILDER HAS A
CAPITAL STOCK THEY'RE TRYING TO
WORK AND THEY'RE GOING TO GET
MONEY OUT OF THAT LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT BUT THEY MAY
NEED THAT LAST FIVE TEN FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT IS SITTING IN A CALIFORNIA
OPPORTUNITIES OWN FUND.
CURRENTLY THERE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FUNDS NATION
WIDE AND I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
HAVING THE NUMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ONES MR GENERAL MAY
KNOW.
HOME HOW MANY THERE ARE EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE I'M SORRY I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY FUNDS THERE --
I'M -- NO I'M SORRY YEAH THAT
THERE ARE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NATIONWIDE MANY OF THEM
ARE FOCUSED ON INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES OR INDIVIDUAL STATES
SOME OF THEM ARE.
FOCUSED ON MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
SOME OF THEM ARE FOCUSED ON JOB
CREATION AND MANUFACTURING.
AND SO PLEASE DO TWO THINGS WHAT
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT.
YOUR ACTION ABOUT HOW THE STATE
OUGHT -- TO PUT TOGETHER THIS
POTENTIAL FOR INVESTMENT IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. TWO
THINGS ONE OF THEM IS MAKE SURE
AS CHRIS POINTED OUT YOU NEED
SOME TRACKING MECHANISM YOU NEED
SOME STATE ORGANIZATION TO WATCH
AND SEE HOW THAT INVESTMENT
WORKED THE OTHER IS KEEP YOUR
MINDS OPEN TO A BROADER
CONFORMITY.
THEN A KIND OF PROJECT BY
PROJECT NARAL -- CONFORMING
TREATMENT I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU
THAT THE CITY OF STOCKTON WHICH
IS SO CALLED OPPORTUNITIES
ALREADY THEY'VE BEEN DOING A LOT
OF WORK HAS ITS OWN REASONS. FOR
PROJECTS THAT ARE THAT WILL
OCCUR IN DOWNTOWN STOCKTON THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE HAS A DIFFERENT
SET.
THEY HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY SO
THAT'S PRIMARILY AN AREA FOR
GROWING MANUFACTURING THAT'S
WHERE THEY WANTED VESTMENT SO
YOU NEED SOME AMOUNT OF
COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION.
IN WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO CONFORM
TO SO DON'T ASSUME THAT IT'S
ONLY.
THE THE SUBMISSION OF PAPERWORK
TO F. T. B. THAT DETERMINES WHAT
GETS CONFORMING TREATMENT BUT
RATHER THE COMMUNITY HAS SOME
INTEREST.
IN SO OP GOOD LUCK -- ON THE
NEXT PHASE WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD
TO LOOKING AT THE TRYING TO LIKE
THANK YOU.
I GUESS WE'LL SIT DOWN THIS
ROUND.
SANTA CORBIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAX REFORM ASSOCIATION -- WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND I'D LIKE TO
AFFILIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF THE ALEJO.
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T HAVE
LANGUAGE IN FRONT OF US SO WE
HAVE TO OPERATE NOT ON WHAT WE
ASSUME BUT WE WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THE EXISTING FEDERAL PROGRAM --
I WOULD REFER YOU TO AN ALL MAKE
SURE YOU ALL HAVE A COPY OF THIS
IN YOUR OFFICE A RECENT REPORT
BY THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER WHICH IN FACT DOES
ANALYZE THE FEDERAL PROGRAM --
AND IDENTIFIES A FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF FLAWS AND
EXPLICITLY STATES -- CONCERN
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE PROGRAM
IS REALLY DESIGNED TO BENEFIT
THE WEALTHY -- WITH POTENTIAL
HARM TO LOW INCOME RESIDENTS AND
SO WE WOULD WANT TO SEE A
PROPOSAL -- CERTAINLY THAT HAD
TRACKING MECHANISMS BUT THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN WE'RE BUDGETING WHERE
PRIORITIZING -- AND YOU KNOW THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO WRITE FULLY
IDENTIFIED OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
WE DO NO WORK AND WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE ENTERPRISE ZONES WAS
THAT IN SPITE OF THE BEST
INTENTIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
IN SPITE OF EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT COMMUNITIES MOST IN NEED
WERE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE --
OR WERE UP SORT OF THE HIGHEST
POTENTIAL TO ACCESS PROGRAMMING
THAT THOSE WERE FREQUENTLY GAMES --
AT THE EXPENSE OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND TAXPAYERS ACROSS
THE STATE AND CERTAINLY WHILE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RESPECT LOCAL
NEED I'M SURE THOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
HOUSING IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
ALSO KNOW.
THAT NAME BE ISM IS A HUGE
PROBLEM AND THAT PRIORITIES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL DON'T
NECESSARILY ALWAYS REFLECT THE
BEST IN CREEK INTEREST.%
OF OUR LOW INCOME TAXPAYERS --
AND SO AS A RESULT WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
THAT THIS WOULD HAVE TO ACTUALLY
DRIVE GENTRIFICATION AN INCREASE
COST PRESSURES ON LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS -- SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE URGE OUR OPPOSITION
ALTHOUGH WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE BUDGET TRAILER
LANGUAGE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE WHOLE SIDE OF OPEN.
MOVING ON TO XIN REVIVE SALES
AND USE TAX EXEMPTIONS DIAPERS
MISTER PRODUCTS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
ALL RIGHT SO -- MAY REVISE WE
PROVIDE AND OF ME REVISED
PROVIDES AN EXEMPTION.
OF FROM SALES AND USE TAX FOR
SALES OF DIAPERS MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS.
I CALIFORNIA GENERALLY TAXES THE
SALE OF ALL TENSION PERSONAL
PROPERTY UNLESS THERE'S A
SPECIFIC EXEMPTION FROM THE
SALES TAX -- IS ALSO A GENERAL
RULE TO FOR SALES TAX ALLOW --
FOR FOR EXEMPTIONS FOR CERTAIN
THE SUSSEX.
THIS PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WRECK RECOGNIZES THE
NECESSITY NATURE OF DIAPERS
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS AND THIS
PROVIDES AN EXEMPTION FROM SALES
TAX -- FOR DIAPERS INTENDED --
INTENDED FOR USE BY CHILDREN AND
FOR MITCHELL PRODUCTS.
THE PURPOSE OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS TO MAKE CERTAIN THE
SUBSIDIES FOR FAMILY MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND PARTICULARLY FOR THE
NEEDIEST FAMILIES.
OF THIS -- THIS EXEMPTION WOULD
WOULD BE BE KEPT ON THE WOULD
SUNSET AT THE END OF TWENTY A.
B. EFFECTIVE JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY IT WOULD SUNSET --
DECEMBER -- THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND ORDER TO ALLOW
FOR THREE FOUR REVIEW TO
DETERMINE THE EFFECTIVENESS.
OF THE EXEMPTIONS WHETHER THE
STATE HAS THE FISCAL CAPACITY TO
CONTINUE THE EXEMPTIONS.
OF THE COST FOR THESE EXEMPTIONS
ARE ESTIMATED AT SEVENTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND.
AND TWENTY IN A NINETEEN TWENTY
AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION AND
202-020-2020 [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE HELLO.
SURF KIRSTINE LA SO -- REGARDING
DIAPERS THE PROPOSED EXEMPTION
WOULD PROVIDE A BROAD BUT
LIMITED BENEFIT TO PARENTS
ALTERNATIVES COULD PROVIDE MORE
SUBSTANTIAL BENEFITS TO PARENTS
WITH THE GREATEST NEEDS FOR
EXAMPLE INSTEAD OF PROVIDING.
THE EXEMPTION FOR A ONE YEAR AND
AN ESTIMATED TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND FIFTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL.
THE STATE COULD FIND ROUGHLY
SIXTEEN HUNDRED CHILD CARE
ADDITIONAL CHILDCARE SLOTS.
AT AND ADDITIONALLY PROVIDE
LOCAL PROGRAMS AND NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SCHOOLS THROUGH
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT OUR REGARDING
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS -- SOME HAVE
RAISED IN EQUITY CONCERN
REGARDING THE APPLICATION OF
SALES TAX TO THESE PRODUCTS ARE
ONE COULD ADDITIONALLY REYES
SIMILAR EQUITY CONCERNS
REGARDING.
THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX AND
SEVERAL OTHER MAJOR PROGRAMS
SUCH AS CAL GRANTS CAL WORKS AND
SS I SS P..
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT ADDRESSING
THIS EQUITY CONCERN IS A POLICY
PRIORITY WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER A BROAD
RANGE OF OPTIONS ACROSS THOSE
PROGRAM AREAS.
FINALLY REGARDING -- THE SUNSET
DATES -- UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THESE EXEMPTIONS WOULD
LAST JUST TWO YEARS -- IN OUR
VIEW OF THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
ENACT THESE EXEMPTIONS.
ARE SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF
FOUR TO TEN YEARS STRIKES US IS
MORE REASONABLE.
I GIVEN THE DIFFERENT POLICY
RATIONALES FOR THE TWO
EXEMPTIONS THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER AN EXPIRATION DATE
TOWARDS THE EARLIER END OF THE
RANGE FOR THE DIAPER EXEMPTION.
AND TOWARDS THE LATER AND FOR
THE MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS EXEMPTION.
ADMINISTRATION COME A CONCLUSION
TWO YEARS.
VERSUS.
FIVE I'M WHAT WAS RATIONALE
BEHIND THE YOU KNOW THE IT'S
IT'S PART OF OUR TRYING TO
TRYING TO KEEP THE BUDGET
RESILIENT BEING ABLE -- TO IT IT
TAKES A TWO THIRDS VOTE TO
REPEAL ANY ANY TAX CUT ANY -- TO
RAISE TAXES AND SO -- WE'RE
WE'RE DOING IT.
WITHIN THE REVENUE THAT WE HAVE.
IN THE MAY REVISE WE CAME UP
WITH ADDITIONAL REVENUE IN THE
BUDGET WINDOW BUT THEN THAT
REVENUE TRAILS OFF IN THE LATER
YEARS AND SO.
WE WANT TO FIND AS MUCH AS WE
CAN BUT WE WE WANT TO GIVE THIS
THE STATE ROOM SO THAT.
IF WE HAVE A RECESSION LET'S SAY
IN A COUPLE OF YEARS.
WE HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DECIDE WHAT PRIORITIES -- WE
WANT TO FIND IN AND WHICH ONES
ARE ARE LESS IMPORTANT AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE WANT.
TO GIVE IT A SHORT WINDOW SO
THAT WE ROOM READ -- RETAIN THE
FLEXIBILITY.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE.
GOING UP IN A PUBLIC COMMENT.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AT
COMMITTEE JEFF NEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES.
I ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THAT MY
COLLEAGUE GENE HEARST WITH URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA.
WENT TO I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST --
BACK FILL FOR THE LOCAL LOSSES
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE SALES TAX
EXEMPTIONS.
WE CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE THE
POLICY CONSIDERATIONS THAT THESE
GERMAN HAVE HAVE GONE OVER --
BUT WE WOULD NOTE THAT THESE
EXEMPTIONS -- WOULD DIRECTLY
REDUCE FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS --
SERVING MANY OF THESE SAME ARE
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
THE SALES TAXES AS YOU ALL KNOW
FUNDS BOTH NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT -- PROP ONE SEVENTY
TWO FOR PUBLIC SAFETY LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION -- AND IN
PARTICULAR TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT THAT WAS A HUGE
SHIFT OF OF BOTH PROGRAM
RESPONSIBILITY AND REVENUE FROM
THE STATE TO LOCALS AND COUNTIES --
SUPPORT FOR THAT CHANGE -- THE
LYNCH PIN OF THAT SUPPORT WAS
THE CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTION A
INCLUDED IMPROPER -- THIRTY
WHICH GUARANTEES A BACK FILL --
OF THOSE FUNDS WITH THE STATE
REDUCES THOSE REVENUES AND WE
BELIEVE THEREFORE THAT THE STATE
IS OBLIGATED TO BACK FILL
SPECIFICALLY FOR TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT LOSSES RELATED. TO
THESE EXEMPTIONS AT MORE
GENERALLY THOUGH WHILE THE STATE
IS TRYING TO DECIDE.
HOW TO BOTH PROVIDE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES AND ALSO PREPARE FOR
THE INEVITABLE COMING RECESSION
A THREE FOURTHS OF COUNTIES ARE
MAKING THE SAME DECISIONS -- BUT
WITH REVENUES THAT HAVE STILL
NOT RETURNED TO PRE RECESSION
LEVELS AND SO -- REDUCING THEM.
A REDUCING ATTACKS THAT ACTUALLY
AFFECTS LOCALS TO A GREATER
EXTENT THAN IT AFFECTS THE STATE
WITHOUT -- WITHOUT PROVIDING A
BACK FILL IS A TROUBLING SO WE
WOULD -- WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A BACK FULL FOR THE THE
LOCAL LOSSES ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE EXEMPTIONS.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS GENOCIDE
TODAY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ALAMEDA WE'RE HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE TAX
EXEMPTION FOR MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE CITY WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE
THE STATE TO EVENTUALLY FIND A
PATHWAY TO ELIMINATING THE
SUNSET AND MAKING THIS TAX
EXEMPTION PERMANENT IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
MISTER MICHAEL WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND WE
TOO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL TODAY THANK YOU.
SMITH ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE A LONG
STANDING POLICY OF OPPOSING TAX
EXPENDITURES OF THIS NATURE --
RECENTLY WE PARTNERED WITH THE
EDUCATION COMMUNITY AS WELL AS
CHILDREN ADVOCATES TO DO AN
ANALYSIS OF TAX EXPENDITURES
LIKE THIS AND JUST THE IN THAT
COST FROM TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
TO TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE
IS OVER FIVE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS TO THESE ITEMS DO ADD UP.
AND SUN SETTING THEM IS QUITE
IMPORTANT -- IN PARTICULAR IN
SPITE OF THE VERY MERITORIOUS --
NATURE OF THESE PROPOSALS AND
AND CERTAINLY THERE ARE OTHERS
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE THE SURE
THAT ARE QUITE MERITORIOUS.
THERE ARE LIKE ADDRESSING A VERY
FINE PROBLEM WITH A MALLET WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE ARE ON IT WHO ARE
UNABLE TO AFFORD DIAPERS.
OR TAMPONS ARE ABLE TO DO SO AND
WE'RE NOT ALLOCATING FUNDING
DIRECTLY TO THAT WE'RE JUST
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE GETS A
LITTLE BIT OF A BENEFIT WHICH
MEANS AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE.
WHETHER OR NOT THE ATC CAN BE
EXPANDED TO COVER IMMIGRANT
FAMILY FAMILIES WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO BE SUBSIDIZING KIM
KARDASHIAN'S BABY'S DIAPERS AND
SO THERE IS A QUESTION TO BE HOT
ABOUT PRIORITIES HERE AND WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU. TO CONSIDER
THAT THANK YOU. FOR TAXES TO THE
BILLING WHICH OKAY -- SO -- SO
THIS ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH WITH
RETAILERS WHO HAVE SALES TAX
COLLECTION REQUIREMENTS A SOLELY
BY VIRTUE SO THEY'RE OUT OF
STATE RETAILERS AND THEY HAVE A
A COLLECTION REQUIREMENTS BY
VIRTUE OF USING A CALIFORNIA
BASED MARKET FACILITATOR. TO
WAREHOUSE AND SHIP THEIR
PRODUCTS -- SO IF IF HER HOW TO
SEE RETAILER SELLS A GOOD THAT
IS STORED IN FACILITIES LOCATED
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE OUT OF STATE REACHED
RETAILER IS REQUIRED TO COLLECT
SALES AND USE TAXES.
MANY THESE RETAILERS ARE NOT
EVEN AWARE OF THEIR TAX
COLLECTION REQUIREMENT SOMETIMES
NOT EVEN AWARE.
THAT THERE ARE GOODS ARE BEING
SOARED -- AND SHIPPED FROM
CALIFORNIA.
CD TFA -- CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION HAS
MADE EFFORTS IN THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS. TO CONTACT THESE
RETAILERS AND INFORM THEM OF
THEIR TAX COLLECTION DUTIES --
UNDER UNDER CURRENT LAW AT CD
TFA CAN REQUIRE PAYMENT OF BACK
TAXES FOR EIGHT YEARS PRIOR TO
THE DATE -- THAT THEY NOTIFY THE
THE RETAILER -- AB.
ONE FORTY SEVEN MAKES IS NO
LONGER AN ISSUE GOING FORWARD OR
AFTER AFTER OCTOBER FIRST OF
THIS YEAR.
BECAUSE IT WILL REQUIRE MARKET
PLACE FACILITATORS -- TO IT WILL
SHIFT THE BURDEN OF COLLECTING
TAXES TO THE MARKETPLACE TO
SEOUL TATERS -- THE LC RETAILERS
WILL NO LONGER HAVE THAT
OBLIGATION -- SO.
CURRENTLY CD TESFAYE CAN LOOK
BACK EIGHT YEARS THIS PROVIDE
SOME PROTECTION TO THOSE
RETAILERS BY LIMITING CDT TFA.
TWO THREE YEAR LOOK BACK
[inaudible]
HELLO.
HOW WE HAVE TWO COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL FIRST IT WOULD CREATE A
BENEFIT FOR SOME FULLY NON COME
FULLY NON COMPLIANT TAXPAYERS
THAT IS UNAVAILABLE TO OTHERWISE
SIMILAR PARTIALLY COMPLIANT
TAXPAYERS?
ON ONE HAND THAT DIFFERENCE
COULD RAISE SOME EQUITY CONCERNS
ON THE OTHER HAND.
FULLY NON COMPLIANT TAXPAYERS
MIGHT NOT HAVE KNOWN THAT THEY
WERE REQUIRED TO COLLECT USE TAX.
IN OUR SECOND COMMENT IS THAT
THE PROPOSED BENEFIT WOULD NOT
BE AVAILABLE TO RETAILERS TO
FILE OR RICH FILE RETURNS OR
MAKE PAYMENTS.
PRIOR TO BEING CONTACTED BY CD
TFA ANY INCENTIVES CREATED BY
THAT PROVISION COULD BE COMPLEX.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. ONE OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THIS ITEM.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK PRIOR I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ON LINE MERCHANTS.
GUILD OF WE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING THIS ITEM
OPEN AND WHILE WE THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION. FOR LIMITING THE
LIABILITY TO THE PAST THREE
YEARS IT IS OUR VIEW THAT THIS
TAX LIABILITY DOES NOT EXIST AT
ALL OR SHOULD NOT EXIST AT ALL.
THIS ITEM HAS A TIE INTO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AB.
SEVENTEEN NINETY LET ME EXPLAIN
JUST BRIEFLY.
WHEN A THIRD PARTY SELLERS SIGNS
UP ON -- FULFILLMENT BY AMAZON
THEY CLICK THROUGH THE
APPLICATION AND THEY ENGAGE IN
SOME CONTRACT.
NOW -- I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN A THIRD
PARTY SELLER PROVIDES A PRODUCT
TO FULFILLMENT BY AMAZON.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
MATERIAL IS GOING TO BE STORED
AS WAS SAID PREVIOUSLY STATED.
AND FURTHER MORE THEY WERE GIVEN
NO NOTICE THAT THEY HAD ANY
SALES TAX LIABILITY INSTEAD.
THE CONTRACT SAYS YOU ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR YOUR TAXES QUOTE
AND QUOTE.
SO I WOULD POINT OUT THAT THEY
WERE NOT NOTIFIED THERE IS A
COMMON MAN MADE THAT CD TFA HAD
NOTIFIED FOLKS.
AND WE'VE HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH CD TFA AND WE HAVE FOUND
THAT THAT.
NOTICE WAS WANTING IN THAT FOLKS
WERE NOT AWARE THROUGH EACH --
MORE -- SOCIAL MEDIA CHANNELS AT
CETERA THAT THERE WAS EVEN THE
POTENTIAL FOR A SALES TAX
LIABILITY.
AS TO THE LIABILITY OWED THE THE
TERM RETAILER IS USED AND WE
DON'T BELIEVE THESE FOLKS ARE
RETAILER.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILL WILL
KNOW FROM HIS LAW SCHOOL
CONTRACTS CLASS.
THERE IS NO PRIVITY OF CONTRACT
THE CONTRACT IS BETWEEN THE
THIRD PARTY SELLER AND
FULFILLMENT BY AMAZON.
THEY CANNOT DICTATE THE RETURN
POLICY TO THE ULTIMATE PURCHASER
NOR CAN THEY HAVE ANY CONTACT
WITH THAT PURCHASER.
IN FACT THEY ARE EXPLICITLY
PROHIBITED FROM DOING SO SO WE
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT THIS IS MORE
IT CAN TO IT I CAN SIGN ME
AGREEMENT.
IN WHICH THE SELLER IN THIS CASE
FOR THE RETAILER REALLY IS
AMAZON AND WHERE BY THEY ARE THE
PLATFORM THERE THE CUSTOMER
INTERFACE.
AND THEY'RE DETERMINING THE
RETURN POLICY AND OTHER THINGS.
TO MS WICKS BILL HER BILL
REQUIRES THAT THESE CONTRACTS BE
IN PLAIN AND ORDINARY IN
UNDERSTANDABLE ENGLISH AND I
WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU THAT THAT
DID NOT OCCUR.
SO THE EFFECT IS CORRECT THAT
THERE THIS IS DISCRIMINATORY 50%
OF THESE -- SO THIRD PARTY
SUPPLIERS ARE OUTSIDE THE
COUNTRY.
CV TFA WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO
REACH THEM AND IN FACT WHEN THEY
TO REACH SOMEONE WHO IS
DOMESTICALLY BASED.
I WILL SUBMIT TO YOU THAT MANY
OF THEM HAVE NO ABILITY TO
COLLECT THE TAX SO THE REVENUE
ANTICIPATED BY HIS.
ITEM WE THINK IS ILLUSORY AND
FINALLY.
I WANT -- TO BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION THAT IN A
RECENT A LATE APRIL EDITORIAL BY
THE LA TIMES -- CITY TFA ADVICE
SOME OF THESE THIRD PARTIES READ
A TAILOR'S THAT THEY COULD
RECOUP THEIR SALES TAX BY GOING
OUT IN REACHING OUT TO THE
CUSTOMERS.
FIRST OF AGAIN THEY WERE ON
THEIR PROHIBITED FROM DOING SO.
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER -- TWO THE
IDEA THAT AFTER THREE YEARS OR
ANY PERIOD OF TIME THAT A THIRD.
PARTY SELLERS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO REACH OUT TO THE PURCHASER
AND COLLECT THE SALES TAX IS
RIDICULOUS AND WE THINK THAT
THERE SHOULD BE NO TAX LIABILITY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BEFORE NEXT BIGGER SPEAKS --
JUST TO LET FOLKS KNOW FOR NEXT
TIME WHEN YOU WERE TO GO OUT OF
ORDER SO GONNA CALL FROM.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN JUST A
HEADS UP.
PLEASE RECEIVE SMITH ACCORDING
TO THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION JUST WANNA KNOW THAT
WE ACTUALLY HAVE NO POSITION ON
THIS ITEM AT THIS TIME ALTHOUGH
WE WERE DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH.
CITY TFA AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BURKE'S OFFICE WITHIN HER
FOR BRINGING FORWARD -- ONE
FORTY SEVEN IN THIS APPEARS TO
BE A COMP OF REASONABLE
COMPROMISE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN.
A MOVE ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN
VOTING SYSTEMS REPLACEMENT FOR
COUNTIES IN TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE
.
CHAIR COOPER IF I MAKE HIM GO
OFFICE OUR COLLEAGUES ARE IN THE
SENATE RIGHT NOW WITH THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES TESTIFYING SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO TAKE SIXTEEN OUT
OF ORDER WERE HERE FOR THAT ITEM.
OR YOU CAN PUT IT TO THE END BUT
WHATEVER YOUR PREFERENCE WILL GO
AND TAKE.
SIXTEEN OKAY THANK YOU.
AND THAT'LL BE CALYX S. IN
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS
EXPENDITURES SEARCH REPLACEMENT
PROJECT [inaudible]
TROUBLING WHICH GOOD AFTERNOON
[inaudible]
AFTER.
MY NAME IS JULIE WHAT DEL I AM
THE CHIEF OF THE POLITICAL
REFORM DIVISION AT THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE AND ON BEHALF
OF SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE
CONTACTS AS PROJECT TEAM.
AT THE APRIL FINANCE OTHER
REQUEST AN AUGMENTATION OF SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AND SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE P.
DATA FUND.
AT THIS WILL ALLOW ATTHIS
CONTINUED FUNDING WILL ALLOW US --
TO MEET THE SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE WHICH WAS ENACTED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND IT WILL CONTINUE
FUNDING FOR CONTRACTED SERVICES
[inaudible]
LL [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
PLEASE.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE TROUBLING
WHICH PLEASE CERTAINLY AND AGAIN
CAN GET TO A AND I'M HERE AS THE
PROJECT SPONSOR OF THE CARS
PROJECT.
AND THE OTHER PORTION OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS A LET'S PROPOSAL TO
CONTINUE THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE
OF THE CALYX AS REPLACEMENT
SYSTEM.
FROM THE CURRENT STATUTORY
DEADLINE OF DECEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN TO AFTER THE
PRESIDENTIAL TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION WE WERE INITIALLY
PROPOSING PERHAPS DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY HOWEVER IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE F. PPC AND
STAKEHOLDERS.
WE REALIZE THAT WILL BE IN THE
MIDS OF A FILING DEADLINE AT
THAT TIME AND PERHAPS A FEBRUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DEADLINE WOULD
BE.
THE BEST -- THE REASON FOR THIS
IS THAT AT THE TIME SB THIRTEEN
FORTY NINE MANDATING THE CALYX
AS REPLACEMENT SYSTEM WAS PASSED
THE PRIMARY WAS SCHEDULED TO BE
IN JUNE WITH THE CHANGE OF THE
PRIMARY TO MARCH WE WILL BE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A MANDATORY FILING
PERIOD.
IF WE GO LIVE IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN SO FILINGS WILL
BEGIN IN THE OLD SYSTEM AND THEN
WILL CONTINUE IN THE NEW SYSTEM.
STAKEHOLDERS AND OTHERS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
IMPLEMENTATION DEADLINE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FINANCE.
CLICK ON THE PART OF FINANCE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
GOING TO OPEN UP PUBLIC COMMENT.
FAVORITE HOLES ON LOCAL STAFFERS
WITH YET SECTORS TO ENSURE THE
BILL LANGUAGE DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION PASS THE TWENTY
TWENTY PRESIDENTIAL ACTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM -- FIRST
HERE ARE THE SAID TESTATOR FOLKS
JUST [inaudible]
ONE WHAT ABOUT.
SORRY BOUNCE AROUND OR DEAL WITH
SOME PERSONAL ISSUES
.
HI. TWELVE GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR THAT WE OF OUR
APOLOGIES WE ACTUALLY JUST CAME
OUT OF THE SENATE.
BUDGET HEARING SO -- SORRY TO
KEEP YOU WAITING HERE.
SO THE SECTOR STATES OFFICE IS
REQUESTING AT EIGHTY SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME GENERAL FUNDING COSTS TO
COVER THE COSTS FOR PLACEMENT OF
VOTING SYSTEMS WHICH INCLUDES
ALL TABULATION EQUIPMENT
ACCESSIBLE EQUIPMENTELECTION
MANAGEMENT SOFTWARE AND HARDWARE
LE TRYING TO PULL BOOKS AND DODD
ON DEMAND PRINTERS.
AS YOU MAY RECALL HER LAST YEAR
AT THIS TIME AND THAT YOU GUYS
GENEROUSLY.
APPROVED A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND FOR PLACEMENT A
COUNTY VOTING SYSTEMS.
THAT REQUEST -- WAS DONE AT A
FIFTY FIFTY MATCH THIS REQUEST
SUPPLEMENTS THAT -- AND MODIFIES
THE REQUEST TO BE AT 2575% MATCH --
FOR COUNTIES SO I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU HELLO.
ADMINISTRATOR THE LA -- AS THE
AGENDA INDICATES WE DID A
RELEASE SOME COMMENTS ABOUT --
THIS PROPOSAL AND I WON'T GO
INTO IT IN SUPER DETAILS AND
CITIZENS INCLUDED IN THE A.
AGENDA BUT THE ONE THING I WOULD
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT OF THE ONE OR
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS --
NONE OF IT HAS BEEN EXPENDED
POSSIBLY FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
NOW.
LOW ON HER OUT -- AND LITTLE
UNDER FIVE OR THOUSAND AND SO IN
IN LARGE PART THOSE BECAUSE OF
DELAYS RELATED TO IMPLEMENTING
FISCALE -- AS WELL AS DELAYS
RELATED TO JUST THE PICTURE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS IN GENERAL.
AND SO WE RAISE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS -- IN OUR ANALYSIS AND
I WAS JUST GONNA HIGHLIGHT ONE
OF THEM IS. TO GET A SENSE OF
WHETHER THE DELAY.
IN THE FUNDING -- TO COUNTIES
HAS -- RESULT IN ANY COUNTIES
NOT.
UPGRADING THEIR VOTE SYSTEMS ARE
PLANNING OUT TO VOTE BUT AFTER
THE ROOT SYSTEMS AND IF.
THE DELAY HAS RESULTED IN SOME
COUNTIES NOT UPDATING THE VOTING
SYSTEMS OF THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER WAYS TO
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD NOTE IS
THAT -- THE PROPOSAL DOES ASSUME
FOR COUNTIES THAT FIFTY OR FEWER
PRECINCTS IN THE NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN ELECTION
THERE'S NO MATCH SO OF THE STATE
WILL PROVIDE FULL FUNDING FOR
THOSE SMALLER INTO -- COUNTIES.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE A QUESTION.
NO NO NO PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA IN
THE COUNTY OF IN TURN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S ME
REVISION PROPOSAL. TO MESS
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES INTO VOTING
MACHINES -- DECERTIFICATION
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
PLEASE A CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF
FINANCIAL PRESSURE ON LOCAL
AGENCIES AND WE VIEW THIS
PROPOSAL IS ASSISTING TO RELIEVE
SOME OF THAT PRESSURE.
FURTHER WE JUST LIKE TO POINT
OUT THAT -- THE STATE REALLY
DOESN'T PARTICIPATE FINANCIALLY
IN ADMINISTRATION OF LOCAL
ELECTIONS WELL WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL -- FOR THE ASSISTANCE
WITH VOTING MACHINES -- WE ARE
RUNNING THESE ELECTIONS -- AT A
LOCAL COSTS SO WE APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT AND NURTURE MOST
POSITIVE CONSIDERATION WHEN IT
COMES BEFORE.
THANK YOU.
JEFF DEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AFTER THE SOS ARE MORE
STATE FUNDS IN A THREE TO ONE
MATCH NECESSARY.
WE BELIEVE THEY ARE YES THERE IS
IN LINE WITH THE OUR REQUEST
LAST YEAR -- IT'S IN ONE IN LINE
WITH THE MATCHING FORMULA THAT
HAS BEEN IN PLACE SINCE
HISTORICALLY IF WITH COUNTIES
BOTH THROUGH THE BMB WITH THE
VOTING ON A STATION WHERE MONEY
AND THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
HAVE A MONEY.
THIS ONE MORE QUESTION OR
UPGRADE THIS ELECTION MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS THEY AS A HIGH PRIORITY
AS UPGRADED VOTING SYSTEMS FOR
SECURE ELECTION.
WE ARE YES SAID THE IT'S SO
ELECTION MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS ARE.
EXISTENCE THE SELF.
THEY ARE WHAT THEY SAY THEY ARE
THEY MANAGE THE ELECTIONS FOR
THE COUNTY SO IT'S IT IS THE
VOTER REGISTRATION THE WHOLE
WORKERS THE PETITIONS THAT ALL
THE ADMINISTRATION OF OF
ELECTIONS SEPARATE APART FROM
THE VOTING SYSTEMS I THINK --
UPGRADING THAT TO THE HIGH
STANDARDS AND AND ALLOWING THE
COUNTY IS THE PROVIDING COUNTY
IS THE ADDITIONAL APPROPRIATION
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT.
A GREAT IS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU IS IMPORTANT THE STATE
PROVIDE ADEQUATE FUNDING TO
ENSURE THE CAT COUNTY ELECTION
SYSTEMS ARE WORKING WELL.
IF THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
PROVIDED WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE ARE ANY DELAYS AND
COUNTIES RECEIVING THIS MONEY.
WILL CONTINUE TO HOLD THIS OPEN
TO ALLOW STAFF TO WORK WITH THE
SOS TO SURE THAT COUNTIES WOULD
RECEIVE THE MONEY IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS REVISION WERE SEVENTEEN
VOTER OUT RICH EDUCATION FOR AS
BEFORE FIFTY HELLO.
AND SO THAT THIS IS A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
OVER TWO YEARS -- TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE FOR OUT
REGION EDUCATION -- FOR COUNTIES
ARE USING THE NEW VOTE CENTER
MODEL FOR VOTING -- SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDE -- ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS -- TO COUNTIES
REIMBURSEMENT SOME FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO SECRETARY STATE FOR
DEVELOPMENT -- DEVELOPING OUR
REGION EDUCATION MATERIALS.
FINANCE.
OBVIOUSLY THIS THAT A DEVIATION
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SO
WE CAN'T SUPPORTED AT THIS TIME
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS.
S. WAS THAT SPEAK -- YEAH THAT
WERE ASKING FOR THIS IS -- AND I
NEVER IN SUPPORT OF FOR NOT
REVIEW ARE YOU.
I KNOW YOU WORK FOR ME WITH
THESE FOLKS THAT KNOW YOU HI
MISTER CHAIR -- ROBBIE OUTLINED
AT THE SECRETARY STATED FOR
POLICY AND PLANNING -- ALSO --
FOR FORMER DESERT DIRECTOR FOR
MISTER COOPER HERE SO.
SO YES IT'S THE FUNDING WOULD BE
FOR A FOR OUT REACH ESPECIALLY
FOR THE COUNTIES THAT ARE COMING
ON BOARD FOR TWENTY TWENTY FOR
THE VOTERS CHOICE ACT.
SO A LOT OF THESE COUNTIES ARE
MUCH LARGER THAN THE COUNTIES
THAT CAME ON BOARD IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO THAT INCLUDES ORANGE
LOS ANGELES FRESNO SANTA CLARA.
AND EL DORADO THAT'S JOINING
WITH MADERA NAPA NEVADA SAN
MATTEO IN SACRAMENTO SO THIS.
THESE FUNDS WILL BE USED FOR OUT
REACHPURPOSES FOR THE COUNTIES
GOING VCA.
TWENTY TWENTY THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
GOING UP IN A PUBLIC COMMENT.
TELL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT -- FOR
THE SOS.
IS A BUDGET BILLING WAS
NECESSARY TO FACILITATE THE
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS A SOLUTION
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
A TO READ AT ONE TIME.
IS ANY BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
NECESSARY TO FACILITATE THE
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS PROPOSAL NO SIR.
OKAY THANK YOU.
YOUR MAX MY VOTER TURNOUT IS
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT
ELECTION OFFICIALS HAVE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE TRANSITION
TO THE VOTER.
CENTER MODEL MAY PROPOSAL
PROVIDE THESE RESOURCES THREE
AND ALL THE SUDDEN OPEN FOR NOW.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN ESTE SO SECURITY
MINISTRATION PROGRAM
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA ISSUE ONE AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WILL ROLL CALL OF THAT ITEM
PLEASE -- THE ACTION WAS TO
ADOPT THE SPRING FISCAL LETTER.
TO THANK YOU MISTER ISSUE --
BACK NINE RATING.
PLEASE PROCEED HI GOOD MORNING
AND GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER
HARRIS WITH THE CALPERS
FINANCIAL OFFICE.
THIS ITEM -- BRINGS TO THE STATE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION
PROGRAM ON BUDGET.
CURRENTLY CALPERS ISTHE STATE'S
DESIGNATED STATE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND IN GENERAL THAT MEANS THAT
WE OVERSEE CONTRACTS BETWEEN
ROUGHLY TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
PUBLIC EMPLOYER STATEWIDE.
AND OF THE STATE OR THE FEDERAL
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION.
FOR SEVERAL YEARS CALPERS WOULD
COLLECT SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS
FROM EMPLOYERS AND DEPOSITED IN
THE OLD AGE SURVIVORS INSURANCE
FUND.
THOSE FUNDS WOULD SIT THERE AND
ACCRUE INTEREST AND THAT
INTEREST IS WHAT CALPERS WOULD
YOU LIES TO COVER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES OF THIS
PROGRAM.
BEGINNING IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY THERE WILL BE
INSUFFICIENT FUNDS IN THE O. S.
I. FUNDS TO COVER ADMINISTRATIVE
EXPENSES.
AND PURSUANT TO CURRENT
STATUTORY AUTHORITY WILL BEGIN
CHARGING AN ASSESSMENT TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS TO OFFER SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS TO THEIR
MEMBERS.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS SURE
WELL [inaudible]
FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GREG TOLL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE SUPPORT THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AND WOULD REITERATE
THAT SIMILAR TO THE AGENDA AND
WHAT CALPERS A STATED -- THIS
LANGUAGE WOULD RING THE YES I
FIND UNDER THE BUDGET APPROVAL
PROCESS TO ENSURE ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERSIGHT AND PROVIDE BETTER
INSIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY INTO
THE PROGRAM.
AND FUND RESERVES MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
GOING UP IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
I WILL CLOSE PUBLIC COMMENT --
QUESTION FOR CALPERS.
WHAT WITH THE FIVE REQUESTED
POSITIONS DO?
WELL THERE CURRENTLY ARE FIVE
POSITIONS WITHIN OUR
ORGANIZATION WHO OVERSEE
CONTRACTS BETWEEN THESE EMPLOYER
STATEWIDE.
AND THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SOARING ALL THIS ITEM OPEN OKAY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
NINETEEN EXCLUDED EXEMPT
EMPLOYEES IT IS A YEAR EIGHTY
EIGHTY EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS
FORMULA FOR NEW THAT'S THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS QUICKLY
TOLL WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO NEEDED TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
SO IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY WAS
INTRODUCED TO REDUCE THE COST
STRUCTURE OF EMPLOYEE AND
RETIREE HEALTH CARE BENEFITS.
AND ELIMINATE THE OPEC UNFUNDED
LIABILITY THE NEW COST
CONTAINMENT STRATEGY CALLED FORM
PLEASE IN THE STATE TO MAKE
EQUAL PRE FUNDING CONTRIBUTIONS
BASED ON THE NORMAL COST OF THE
RETIREE HEALTH.
BENEFITS.
IN ADDITION TO EQUAL COST
SHARING BETWEEN THE STATE AND
EMPLOYEES TO PRE FUND RETIREE
HEALTH CARE.
THROUGH THE BARGAINING PROCESS
NEW EMPLOYEES ARE NOW SUBJECT TO
LOWER EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION FOR
FUTURE RETIREE HEALTH BENEFITS
KNOWN AS THE 8080% CONTRIBUTION
FORMULA.
AND ARE ALSO SUBJECT TO A LONGER
VESTING PERIOD TO QUALIFY FOR
THE RETIREE HEALTH CARE
CONTRIBUTION.
CURRENT LAW SPECIFIES THAT THE
8080% EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION FOR
NEW TENTS APPLIES TO ALL TWENTY
ONE BARGAINING UNITS.
RANK AND FILE EMPLOYEES RELATED
EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES AND STATE
EMPLOYEES OF THE JUDICIAL BRANCH.
THIS MAYOR REVISION PROPOSAL FOR
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SEEKS
TO AMEND EXISTING GOVERNMENT
CODE TO REMOVE AMBIGUITY AND
ENSURE THAT BENEFITS FOR EXAMS
AND EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES.
ALIGNS WITH THE STATE'S OTHER.
AND POST EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS PRE
FUNDING POLICIES FOR ALL STATE
EMPLOYEES WITH THA I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
QUESTION WOULD BE THE IMPACT OF
NOT ADOPTING THIS LANGUAGE.
ABSENT THIS LANGUAGE -- THE NEW
NEW EMPLOYEES HIRED INTO AN EXAM
TO ARE EXCLUDED POSITION WILL
FALL UNDER THE EXISTING LAW FOR
THE ONE HUNDRED NINETY EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTION FORMULA SO RIGHT
NOW IN STATUTE -- BECAUSE IT'S
NOT SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFYING
EXCLUDED AND AND EXEMPTS TO THE
EIGHTY EIGHTY FORMULA THAT WE
ADOPTED A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
NEW EXEMPTION EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES
WILL NOW CONTINUE TO FALL UNDER
THE ONE HUNDRED NINETY FORMULA.
AS LONG AS THEY VAST AND STATE
SERVICE FOR THE REQUIRED PERIOD
OF TIME SO THEY'LL BE ELIGIBLE
FOR HIGHER BENEFIT WHICH DOES
NOT ALIGN WITH.
OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES.
THANK YOU LL.
GOING UP IN A PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN [inaudible]
HE WON YEAH OKAY
.
WE'RE STILL MOVE AROUND A LITTLE
BIT SO WE'RE GONNA NEXT TO THE
B. ISSUE NUMBER -- TEN SPRING
FISCAL LETTER [inaudible]
THE SCOUT
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN.
HI MY NAME IS MERRIAM BARCELONA
ENGINEER NOW AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF FISCALE.
AND THEN A LOT OF APPILY OUT
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE.
I'M JAN ROSS I AM THE CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER FOR THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
SITTING IN FOR GEORGE LOIS.
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN AND BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY WE HAVE A
SPRING FINANCE LETTER THAT
REQUESTS. THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET YEAR
TWENTY FOUR POINT SEVEN MILLION
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THE
MAJORITY OF THAT AMOUNT WHICH IS
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS IS
REALLY GOING TOWARDS THE SUPPORT --
OF THE DEPARTMENTS AND
ENHANCEMENTS AND NEEDED TO THE
SYSTEM TO MAKE THEIR USE OF THE
SYSTEM.
MORE STRAIGHT FORWARD AND MORE
EFFECTIVE AND THE REMAINING SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IS.
IN JUST THE FIRST YEAR AND THAT
IS TO COMPLETE THE SCO
FUNCTIONALITY WHICH WE ARE
PUSHING OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FULLY TASKED
INTO FULLY.
ENABLE THE DEPARTMENTS TO COME
IN AND VALIDATE THAT THE CHANGES%
HAVE AN IMPACT OTHER PARTS OF
THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE AN
ANTICIPATED [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
BRENT METZ GIRL A WE AGREE WITH
THE STAFF'S RECOMMENDATION TO
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN WE DO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS CURRENTLY
WORKING ON A NEW SPECIAL PROJECT
REPORT FOR THIS PROJECT.
I TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
WE REYES AND PRIOR HEARINGS ON
FISCAL AS WELL AS TO RE BASELINE
THE PROJECT BECAUSE COST
SCHEDULE IN SCOPE -- HOWEVER WE
DO WANT TO OUTLINE THE SHORT
TIME WHEN THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS TO CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL
RELATIVE TO THE NEW S. P. R. --
FISCAL PROJECT TEAM IS EXPECTING
TO SUBMIT A NEW S. P. ARE
RELATIVELY SHORTLY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY.
HAS INDICATED THEY WILL NEED AT
LEAST TEN CALENDAR DAYS TO
EVALUATE THIS.
I WITHOUT THIS UPDATED PROJECT
PLAN THE LEGISLATURE IS MISSING
CRITICAL INFORMATION TO CONSIDER
THIS PROPOSAL -- SUCH AS HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION ARRIVED AT THE
AMOUNTS REQUESTED IN THE
PROPOSAL.
IN ADDITION WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER REQUIRING
THE ADMINISTRATION TO FIVE
IDENTIFYING CALCULATE THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING AND POSITIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN APPROVED FOR
DEPARTMENTS TO TRANSACT IN FITS
CAL -- TO TO DATES IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AT LEAST NINE DEPARTMENTS
HAVE REQUESTED ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IN POSITIONS TO TRANSACT
IN FISCAL AND NOW THE DEPARTMENT
FISCALES REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. TO HELP DEPARTMENTS
TO TRANSACTING FISCALE WITHOUT
KNOWING WHAT FUNDING IN
POSITIONS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED AND HOW THOSE
COMPLEMENT THE RESOURCES
REQUESTED BY DEPARTMENT OFFICE
CAL LEGISLATURE'S AGAIN MISSING
CRITICAL INFORMATION.
FINANCE.
VETERAN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDE
THESE RESOURCES ARE NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO HELP DEPARTMENTS CLOSE
THEM UP FROM THEIR MONTH AND
THEN YOUR AND CLOSES IN A TIMELY
FASHION.
WE WOULD NOT THAT THIS IS A
REQUEST OR PROVIDE STATEWIDE
RESOURCES TO DEPARTMENTS AND NOT
JUST -- INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENTS --
WHICH HAVE ALSO REQUESTED SOME
RESOURCES RELATED TO FISCAL IN
THE PAST.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
I'M GOING TO OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT.
CASEY NOR SPEAK RECENTLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SIX WILL HEAR ALL
THE JOINT HEARING ASSEMBLY
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE FIFTH CAL
SYSTEM ON JUNE NINETEENTH WE
NINETEEN THRILL THIS ITEM OPEN.
WHAT DO I THINK IT'S NOT HIM
THANK YOU?
NUMBER.
TEN CALIFORNIA STATE PAYROLL
SYSTEM I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
ELEVEN PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBER.
MEMBERS HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
URBAN I'M WITH THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AS HE WAS
REQUESTING SIX PERMANENT
POSITIONS AND FUNDING TO SUPPORT
DATA CONVERSION AND INDEPENDENT
VERIFICATION AND VALIDATION OUR
IBM BE CONSULTANT CONTRACTS TO
CONTINUE.
EFFORTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PAYROLL SYSTEM PROJECT THESE
REQUESTED RESOURCES WILL
CONTINUE DEVELOPING MIDLEVEL
SOLUTION REQUIREMENTS.
AND WORKING THROUGH THE
REMAINING PAL ACTIVITY --
DELIVERABLES WHICH WILL DRIVE
THE PROCESS FOR ASSESSING
OPTIONS AND DESIGNING A NEW
STATE WIDE PAYROLL APPROACH FOR
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE FINANCE.
I'M SUSAN ROOK ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE GOVERNOR AS MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL SUPPOSED TO
CONTROL ITS ONGOING EFFORTS
TOWARD TO PLACING.
THE STATE'S PAYROLL SYSTEM YES
SUPPORTIVE OF IT HELLO.
METZGER LA -- WE JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS PROJECT IS STILL
GOING THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE BUT THE B. C. P.
REQUEST PERMANENT RESOURCES. FOR
LARGELY POWER RELATED ACTIVITIES
AND SO -- WE'RE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF EVALUATING THIS
PROPOSAL BUT WE HAVE ASKED THE
ADMINISTRATION WHY THESE
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED ONAN
ONGOING BASIS GIVEN THE PROJECT
HAS NOT STARTED -- WE'VE ALSO
NOTED IN OUR COMMENTS TO STAFF
THAT THIS -- PROJECT IS STILL
GOING THROUGH STAGE TWO OF POWER --
AND THAT IT THAT STAGE WILL
REQUIRE THE PROJECT TO EVALUATE
SEVERAL POTENTIAL IT SOLUTIONS
AND UPON CSUS SELECTING A
PREFERRED SOLUTION ESTIMATE THE
COST GADGIL IN SCOPE OF THE
PROJECT GOING FORWARD -- IN OUR
PREVIOUS COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL OUR THIS PROJECT I'M
SORRY WE HAVE RECOMMENDED
LEGISLATURE DIRECT THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO PRESENT
ITS FULL FINDINGS THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEANINGFUL INPUT.
AND WEIGH IN WITH ITS OWN
SELECTED -- THIS BCP HOWEVER
DOES NOT PROVIDE A SPECIFIC DATE
WHEN THE STATE'S TO DOCUMENT
WILL BE SUBMITTED AND SO WE'VE
ASKED THE MINISTRATION FOR THOSE
SPECIFIC DATES TO BETTER INFORM
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
QUESTION FOR THE COMMITTEE.
OVER THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
CARE TO HOLD SADDAM OPEN THANK
YOU WITH ONE ARE EXCITED BECAUSE
YOU NEVER TWELVE FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
.
WELL THE BOSS FOR SECOND I WANNA
GO BACK -- TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE
AND ON THE YES.
THANK YOU MISTER THERE IN.
PLEASE PROCEED VERY EFFICIENT
THANK YOU JIM COOPER MY NAME IS
JASON KENNEY ABOUT EVERY
DIRECTOR FOR REAL ESTATE
SERVICES THE TGS -- THE PROPOSAL
IN FRONT OF YOU IS A ONE TIME
ASK OF TWO POINT ONE SIX EIGHT
MILLION TO CONDUCT SITE
ASSESSMENTS.
OF THE VERY DON'T KNOW CENTER
COSTA MESA THE PROPERTIES ON THE
JURISDICTION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WHICH
IS THE PROCESS OF CLOSING THE
REMAINING CENTER STATEWIDE.
THE LAST CLIENTS SLATED TO LEAVE
THE CENTER BY DECEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN AFTER THAT DDS WILL
MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY IN THE
STATE OF ONE SHUT DOWN.
THE CAMPUS IS EXTENSIVE TOTALING
HUNDRED TEN ACRES AN APPROXIMATE
HUNDRED SIXTEEN BUILDINGS HAS
BEEN OPERATION FOR DECADES THE
PROPOSAL WOULD STUDY THE SITE
WOULD RESULT IN A PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE REPORT THAT OUTLINES
BUILDING CONDITIONS.
THE STATE OF SITE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ABATEMENT DEMOLITION COSTS
ETCETERA -- THE FUNNY WOULD NOT
BE USED TO DISPOSE OF THE
PROPERTY OF THE PROPERTY HAS NOT
BEEN DOES APPEAR BUT LEGISLATURE
A SURPLUS YET THE FUNDING
HOWEVER IS CRITICAL. TO THE
SUCCESSFUL FUTURE DESPITE THIS
POSITION OF THE PROPERTY IN FOUR
WAYS ONE IT WOULD ALLOW THE CITY --
THE STATE AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
A DETAILED LOOK INTO THE
CONDITION OF THE CAMPUS TO IT
WOULD SET EXPECTATIONS AND A
COMMON VERNACULAR ABOUT THE SITE
ITSELF IN ITS CURRENT CONDITION.
THREE IT WOULD HELP PLANNED
FUTURE RE USE OF THE SITE WHERE
APPLICABLE AND FOR WOULD SPEED
UP THE OVERALL PROCESS -- A
DISPOSITION -- LOWERING STATE
SHUT DOWN COSTS THANK YOU.
HELLO.
FIND CRISTINA CONCERNS FINANCE
THE CONCERTS IN A COMMENCEMENT
COMMITTEE.
OVER THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
GIVEN ALL THIS ITEM OPEN.
WE GOT ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
POINT TWENTY CENSUS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUSTIN
HOWARD -- DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
WITH ME IS THAT THE DIRECTOR OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS OFFICE
AND CALIFORNIA DE TO SCOGGINS --
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IS --
I'M A REVISION REQUEST TO
AUGMENT OUR CURRENT -- STATE
SINCE THE SEPARATES -- BY --
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR OUTREACH
RELATED TO OUR NATIVE AMERICAN --
OR NATIVE AMERICAN GOVERNMENTS --
SPECIFICALLY -- WHAT WE HAVE
FOUND OVER THE LAST?
SEVERAL MONTHS IN DEALING WITH
THAT NATIVE AMERICAN
ORGANIZATIONS OF THEIR VERY
UNIQUE AND THE NATURE OF HOW
THEY ARE ESTABLISHED AND HOW WE
NEED TO CONDUCT OUTREACH WITH
THEM -- WE'VE ALREADY PROVIDED
SOME LEVEL FUNDING DIRECT
APPLICATIONS TO THOSE NATIVE
AMERICAN -- GOVERNMENTS AS WELL
AS SPECIFIC COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS -- TO DO DIRECT
OUT REACH WE HAD ANTICIPATED
THAT WE'RE ALSO GOING TO HAVE --
SOME OF OUR OTHER PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS THERE ARE MINISTRY
OF COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AS WELL AS THE COUNTIES DO SOME
MORE SOME KIND OF INDIRECT OUT
REACH TO THE SAME THE SAME
POPULATION GROUP BUT AFTER AND
HAVING CONVERSATIONS.
WITH THE TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS WE
FOUND IT WILL BE BEST IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE STATE TWO
INCH TO PROVIDE THAT -- OUT
REACH DIRECTLY INSTEAD OF HAVING
TO GO INDIRECTLY THROUGH SOME OF
OUR PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS SO
HENCE THE CHANGE OF COURSE HERE
IN IN REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
MONEY -- FOR NATIVE AMERICAN OUT
REACHED ADDITIONALLY WERE ASKING
FOR NINE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- TO DO TWO
THINGS ONE IS TO ACQUIRE --
POLITICAL DATA EAKES -- TOOL
THIS IS BASICALLY A CANVASSING
TOLL THAT WE CAN UTILIZE AS WE
CONDUCT -- DOOR DOOR CAMPUS
SCENE DURING THAT NON RESPONSE
FOLLOW UP PERIOD AND SO THAT WE
CAN TRACK AND COLLECT THE DATA
OF THOSE LOCATIONS WHERE WE ARE --
DOING THAT OUR REGION THE
COMMUNITY -- AND WE'RE ALSO
ASKING FOR FUNDING FOR AN
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THAT WE CAN
DO THE NECESSARY STATISTICAL
ANALYSIS DEVELOP SOME BASELINE
MEASURES AND METRICS FOR SUCCESS
RELATED TO OUR STATEWIDE
OUTREACH AND RAPID DEPLOYMENT
TOOL.
ON THE THIRD COMPONENT OF THIS
IS A REALLY A TECHNICAL CHANGE
OR ASKING FOR MILLION DOLLARS IN
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY SO THAT
pEXPAND FUNDING THAT COMES TO US
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
THIS IS RELATED TO THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING POPULATION
SAMPLE NUMERATION SURVEY WHICH
IS PARTLY FUNDED BY BOTH THE
CENSUS OFFICE AS WELL THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE CENSUS
OFFICES CARRYING THE CONTRACT --
BUT THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
CONTRIBUTED A MILLION DOLLARS TO
THAT CONTRACT AND WE NEED THE
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY IN ORDER
TO EXPAND THOSE FUNDS ONCE THEY
REACH OUR OFFICE -- FOR WE HAVE
TO PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE REQUEST --
THAT WE'RE ALSO ASKING FOR AND
THE BIG ONE IS REALLY REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL -- BUDGET FLEXIBILITY
AND IT'S THE ONE I'M IT'S BEEN A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME MINDS -- TO
KIND OF LAY THE GROUNDWORK HERE
AND WE KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF REQUESTS
FROM VARIOUS -- STAKEHOLDERS OUT
THERE SAYING THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE MORE MONEY FOR CENSUS
OUT REACH HOWEVER IN THE VIEW OF
THE STATE AT THE MINISTRATION OF
THIS TIME TIME WE CANNOT
DETERMINE WHETHER WE NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR CENSUS
OUR RATES WERE ALREADY PROVIDING
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE GRAND
SCHEME.
OF EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE ASKED
FOR SPENDING A HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
CENTS TWENTY SEVENTEEN THROUGH
THE SENSES PERIOD JUST ON CENSUS
RELATED ACTIVITIES -- AS WE WORK
THROUGH THE SUMMER WE ARE GOING
TO BE HONING IN AND GETTING DOWN
TO THE GROUND YOUR LEVEL ON
ROUTE REACH PLANS AS WE DO THAT
WILL BE IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO TELL YOU
EXACTLY.
WHETHER WHERE WE ARE SPENDING
OUR DOLLARS WHAT TYPE OF
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES WE ARE
CONDUCTING IN THE COMMUNITIES
WHAT POPULATION GROUPS ARE WE
CONDUCTED AN OUT REACH.
ACTIVITIES TO AND WHETHER OR NOT
WE'VE MISSED ANYBODY OR MISSED
ANYTHING AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES THAT WE EXPECT TO DO.
IF OUR CONTRACTOR PARTNERS ARE
DOING A GOOD JOB THEY'RE
DEVELOPING GOOD CONTENT THERE
USING THE CORRECT MESSENGERS --
WE MAY HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO DO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO RIGHT NOW BUT
IF NOT OR IF WE COME TO FIND AS
WE DO OUR IMPLEMENTATION PLANS
THAT WE HAVE A SHORTFALL WE MAY
NEED TO ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND BECAUSE THE CENSUS
PROCESS DOES NOT.
LINE UP WITH THE BUDGET PROCESS
IT MAKES SENSE TO HAVE A LITTLE
BIT OF FLEXIBILITY FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO COME BACK IN REQUEST TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THAT WE IDENTIFY THAT NEED -- SO
THAT'S THAT REQUEST THAT THE
LAST PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IS
REALLY A TECHNICAL.
LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS THE
GOVERNOR TO MAKE TO POINT THE
POSITIONS AS PART OF THE CENSUS
OFFICE AND CLARIFIES THAT THOSE
POSITIONS -- SHOULD AND NO LATER
THAN THE END OF JUNE AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO WITH THAT I'M.
ABLE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS --
FOR YOU TODAY FINANCE
[inaudible]
L. L..
COME IS THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
PUBLIC COMMENT.
MR TURN MEMBERS COULD EASE ON
TARGET FOR THE BATHROOM PROJECT
CALIFORNIA HERE REPRESENTING
CENSUS POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK --
BEFORE I RUN OUT OF TIME AND
DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY I
WANTED KNOWLEDGE YOUR STAFF'S
COMMITMENT AND WILLINGNESS TO
ADDRESS AND CUT OUR CONCERNS.
ENOUGH THOUGHTFUL MANNER SO
THANK YOU CHRISTIAN -- AS
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE MANY PARTIES TO CHOOSE FROM.
ON AND AS YOU DELIBERATE WHAT IS
THE PRIORITY AMONG SUCH CATION
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS -- AT THE
TRIAL PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THAT.
ARE THESE NEEDS -- BEEN FINDING
OUT FOR THESE ISSUES ARE CAN
POSSIBLY EXASPERATED -- IF THERE
IS NOT IF THERE'S AN UNDERCOUNT
AND THAT SO FOR AND THAT'S OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
IF THE SUN SAYS IS NOT DONE
RIGHT THE STATE WILL BE BACK
FEELING THOSE FUNDING GAPS FOR
THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
SO WHY NOT INVEST IN CENSUS
ESPECIALLY CBO'S AND I'M JUST
GONNA MAKE A CASE FOR CBO'S Y.
CBO'S. FOR INSTANCE MISTER CHAIR --
WHY WOULD A MUSLIM AMERICAN
WHO'S A DOCTOR LIVING IN ELK
GROVE CALIFORNIA?
WOULD FILL OUT A CENSUS -- GIVEN
THAT THERE'S A LOOMING THREAT OF
MUSLIM REGISTRY AND THE WHITE
HOUSE.
WHY WOULD A THIRTY FIVE YEAR OLD
WOMAN RAISING TWO BEAUTIFUL
CHILDREN WITH HER UNDOCUMENTED
HUSBAND?
FILL OUT THE CENSUS WITH THERE'S
A LOOMING THREAT THAT HER
HUSBAND CAN BE DEPORTED.
AND THEIR LIVES TOGETHER FOREVER
THREATENED.
WHY WOULD A REFUGEE ON
IMMIGRANTS SEEKING POLITICAL
ASYLUM FILL OUT THE CENSUS IF IT
WILL ONLY TAKE ONE EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO PUT THEM OUT OF THIS
COUNTRY?
THERE ARE THOUSAND THOUSANDS OF
MILLIONS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA YOU NEED CBO'S TO
MOBILIZE EDUCATE AND CONVEYANCE
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
INDIVIDUALS IN A COMMUNITIES WHO
DIRECTLY HAVE NOTHING TO GAIN
BUT A LOT TO LOSE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT POTENTIALLY
WELL EDUCATED HIGH FUNCTIONING
INDIVIDUALS OF OUR SOCIETY WHO
WERE INTO AN INFILL INFLUENTIAL
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
THE STATE NEEDS TO SPEND THIS
MONEY TO EDUCATE AND CONVEYANCE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO WON'T BE
CONVINCED UNLESS THEY HEAR FROM
THOSE DAY TRUST.
WE AGREE IT IS UNPRECEDENTED
AMOUNT OF MONEY WE WILL EVER
SPEND ON THE CENSUS BUT THESE
ARE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES AND DO
WE REALLY WANT TO BE IN A
POSITION TWO YEARS DOWN THE ROAD
AND SAY.
WE WISH WE COULD HAVE DONE A
LITTLE MORE THAT WE DID HAVE THE
CAPACITY IN MEANS TO DO SO.
BUT IT DOES SOUND LIKE A LOT OF
MONEY.
MEMBERS YOU HAVE YOU MAY NOT BE
HERE TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS TEN
YEARS DOWN THE ROAD BUT YOU WILL
BE HERE TWO YEARS FROM NOW
LIVING WITH THESE CONCRETE
CONSEQUENCES OVER. FOR THE
UNDERCOUNT SO I URGE YOU TO SIT
DOWN WITH US LISTEN TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND EMPOWER
US.
AND FUND US ADEQUATELY TO
MOBILIZE EDUCATE AND CONVEYANCE
WHO ARE DOUBTFUL MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- WE READ THE B. C.
P. -- AND THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED -- IN B. C. P. WE BELIEVE
THEIR UNFOUNDED WE HAVE SHARED
SORT OF OUR ANALYSIS WITH THE
STUFF ON THAT AS WELL BE HAPPY
TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE OUR MONTHLY SANTA BE
HAPPILY COUNTY.
WE CONTINUE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS RALLY
COUNTY FOR OUR SENSES OUR REGION
EDUCATION -- WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT -- ARE HARD TO
COME POPULATION AND BELIEVE THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WILL HELP --
LA COUNTY COME UP WITH A
ACCURATE CENSUS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SAM DASH WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION -- WE APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING PROVIDED FOR EDUCATION
SECTORS FOR OUR REACH WE HAVE
MADE A REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
WE SUPPORT MOVING FORWARD OF THE
COMPANY NOW SO WE CAN START THE
WORK FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WHICH IS THE HIGHEST HARD TO
COUNT COUNTY IN THE NATION.
WITH A FOUR TO WORK WITH
ADMINISTRATION AND COMMITTEE.
ATTENTION THE MOST ACCURATE
COUNSEL FOR CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
FAMILIES THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A SPIN
ON THINK ABOUT I WOULD CHEAT Là --
WE ARE A TRUSTED MESSENGER AND
AND A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION.
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
ADVANCE AND PROTECT THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OF IMMIGRANTS AND AND OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND REFUGEES
AS WELL -- WE WANTED TO THANK
THE STATE FOR THE FOR THE
FUNDING THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY
PROVIDED FOR SENSE OUT REACH --
WE WOULD LIKE TO STATE THAT WE
BELIEVE ALONG WITH OUR ADVOCATES
IN THE SENSE POLICY ADVOCACY
NETWORK -- THAT WE NEED MORE
RESOURCES TO CONDUCT A CBO
CENSUS OUT REACH -- CHIRLA
SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE -- A CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT TEAM AT THAT DOES --
PHONE BANKING AND HAS COME A
CONTACTED LOW PROPENSITY VOTERS
IN THE PAST -- IN THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY -- TOUGH ACTIVELY
MOBILIZE OUR POLITICAL POWER --
AND THAT WORK IS NOT CURRENTLY
RECEIVING ANY FUNDING FROM A
FROM THE STATE.
AND SO IT'S WORK LIKE THAT THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO CONTINUE THAT
WE HOPE TO SEE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
FOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
HAS TO BE AN ENEMY DOES NOT KNOW
WHAT CHILDREN NOW WE'RE ALSO
MEMBER OF CENSUS POLICY ADVOCACY
NETWORK -- WE APPRECIATE THE
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
LISTENING TO US HOLDING THIS
ITEM OPENED CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION -- CHILDREN YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE PART OF EVERY HARD
TO COUNT COMMUNITY -- SOME OF
THE YOUNG CHILDREN LIVING ARE
LOW AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES HIGH
POVERTY NEIGHBORHOODS MAKE
STATUS HOUSEHOLDS -- LIVING AND
COMPLEX FAMILY SITUATIONS --
WHERE HOME WHERE ENGLISH IS NOT
THE FIRST LANGUAGE?
EVEN HOMELESS CHILDREN.
THESE ARE DIFFICULT CAO --
DIFFICULT TO COUNT COMMUNITIES
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED A TRUSTED
MESSENGERS THE CBO IS -- THAT
HAVE INVENTED AND HAVE.
PARTNERED WITH THE STATE ON
MULTIPLE OUTREACH EFFORTS -- TO
BE FULLY FUNDED SO I THINK WE
NEED TO THE TO THE CONVERSATION
AND WE HOPE THAT THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL -- ALLOCATION TO
ENSURE THAT THIS CBO OUT REACHES
IS ROBUST AND THAT THE CENSUS
EFFORT IS IS ADEQUATE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE WEB BOTTOM --
WITH CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ON BEHALF
OF OUR FARM WORKER RURAL
CONSTITUENTS WE LANDMARK
COMMENCED WITH C. PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUDY ROBINSON
CENSUS MANAGER FOR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
WOULD LIKE TO REITERATE THE NEED
AND THE OUR REQUEST FOR AN
ADDITIONAL THREE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE WOULD BE
PASSING THROUGH TO OUR COMMUNITY.
WORKING WITH SCHOOLS TO HELP
LEVERAGE THE MINIMAL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING BOTH.
THAT OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE SCHOOLS
HAVE IN WORKING WITH OUR
COMMENTS ON OF THE YOUNG LADY
FROM THE ADVANCEMENT PROJECT IN
THE ELK GROVE EXAMPLE SHE'S
POINT ON WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
COMPLETING OUR STRATEGIC PLAN
AND SUBMITTING IT TO THE STATE.
THE EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE BUT IT IT'S
SEVERELY UNDER FUND SACRAMENTO
IN ORDER FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THE GOALS OF THE STATE AND
HAVE AS COMPLETE ACCOUNT AS
POSSIBLE SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU FIVE QUESTION FOR THE
NOT FOR EMAIL -- IS IT WOULD
EARLY TALKED ABOUT THE OUT REACH
TO THE NATIVE AMERICAN.
EFFORTS SO THIS TWO POINT NINE
MILLIONS ADDITIONAL MONEY SO THE
PREVIOUS MONIES WHAT IS BEEN
DEALT WITH THAT OUT REACHED FOR
NATIVE AMERICANS.
AND IT WAS A BIT EXACTLY CAN YOU.
SO I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY TWO
MILLION ADDITIONAL FOR NATIVE
AMERICAN AND WE'VE ALREADY
ALLOCATED AND THAT -- UP TO ONE
POINT ONE MILLION OF WHICH WE
MAY TWO FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR CONTRACT AWARDS TO
SPECIFIC COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THESE ARE NATIVE
AMERICAN BASE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AND WE'VE.
HAD ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THOUSAND AND
DIRECT -- ALLOCATIONS TO TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS SO THAT THEY COULD
DO OUT REACH WITHIN THEIR
GEOGRAPHICAL SERVICE AREA WITH
THE NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION.
THE THE THE DIFFICULTY OF OR
BECOMES IS THAT MOST OF THEM
DON'T RESIDE WITHIN THEIR THE
LARGE PORTIONS OF THEM DON'T
LIVE ON TRIBAL LANDS ANYMORE SO
THEY LIVE OFF TRIBAL LANDS OF
WERE ASKING THE GOVERNMENT'S
ACTUALLY DO THE OUT REACH ON
THEIR TRIBAL LANDS.
AND MANY OF THEM WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS
ARE ON THE TRIBAL LANDS IT'S
VERY LOW THAT'S WHY THEY GET THE
DIRECT ALLOCATION TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IS NOT.
THAT HIGH BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
CAPTURE THE NATIVE AMERICAN
POPULATION WHO DON'T LIVE ON
TRIBAL LANDS THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS
WELL AS THROUGH -- SPECIFIC
MEDIA RELATED CONTRACT THAT WE
PLAN TO EXECUTE THAT'S GOING TO
BE DEDICATED JUST TO NATIVE
AMERICAN OUR SO THE TWO GROUPS
ARE CALIFORNIA INDIAN MANPOWER
CONSORTIUM MUCH STATEWIDE WE USE
THEM FOR OUR REGION -- SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND THEN ALSO --
CALIFORNIA A NATIVE OF BOTH
PROJECT.
USING THE INFORMATION WHAT YOU
GUYS HAVE DONE SO FAR AS FAR AS
I REALLY GOES.
EXACTLY WHO'S BEEN ROUTE REACHED
A WHAT TRIBES.
GET THAT THAT BE GREAT THAT SIZE
ONCE A TO THE SPEAKERS AND CBO'S --
STAFF REASONS HELD OPEN IS STAFF
TALKED ABOUT IT STEPH A SOCK TO
YOU A LINK ABOUT IT SO WE
REALIZE THE ISSUES. FOR FROM YOU
SEVERAL TIMES DURING HEARINGS IN
THE WE GET IT -- MISSED WICKS MR
CHU ARE CHAMPIONS OF IT --
WITHDRAWING MONEY AT IT -- WE
CAN'T THROUGH A BILLION DOLLARS
AT I MEAN OBVIOUSLY FOR THE
BILLION DOLLARS.
THE VIOS THEY'D USE ALL THE
BILLION DOLLARS SO THIS PLACE
GOT BE WHAT'S GONNA BE AFFECTING
PEOPLE'S VOTERS OUT THERE.
WE'RE JUST CONCERNED THAT
THERE'S TO BE UNDER COUNTER THE
CENSUS WE GET IT.
WE LIVE IN THE VAST BUBBLE WE GO
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS EVERY
WEEKEND WHO WE TALKED TO THE
EMAILS THEY CALL US.
SO JUST SO YOU KNOW WE GET IT
RUN THE SAME PAGE.
SO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING TO WORK WITH MOST
EFFECTIVE THRESHOLDS ITEM OPEN.
NEXT ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
DISASTER RECOVERY FUNDING.
RESERVE FOR TEMPORARY
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN GOOD
AFTERNOON DIRK SEVEN START OF
FINANCE.
OF THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES TEN
POINT FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN THE
RECOVERY.
FROM THE UNPRECEDENTED
DEVASTATION THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WILDFIRES.
AS THE AGENDA KNOWS THE
MINISTRATION PROPOSES FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE CITIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS LOCATED
THERE IN. FOR PROPERTY TAX
LOSSES INCURRED AS A RESULT OF
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES.
THIS REQUEST AUGMENTS THE THIRTY
ONE POINT THREE MILLION THAT WAS
PART OF THE GENERAL FUND BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHICH WAS SUBSEQUENTLY
AMENDED IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET.
THE MAYOR VISION ALSO INCLUDES
TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THE CAMPFIRE RECOVERY EFFORTS.
THE PARADISE IRRIGATION DISTRICT
HAS REQUESTED FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THEIR OPERATIONS FOR A PERIOD OF
THREE YEARS THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL WORK WITH THE DISTRICT TO
DETERMINE IMMEDIATE FUNDING GAPS
AS A RESULT OF THE CAMPFIRE.
AND WANTS TO HELP SUPPORT THE
DISTRICT MAINTAIN CORE SERVICES
DURING THE RECOVERY PERIOD.
CONTINGENT UPON THE DISTRICT
PROVIDING LONG TERM PLAN FOR
SUSTAINABLE WATER SYSTEM THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH STATE LOCAL
POLICIES AND PRIORITIES.
IN ADDITION A PORTION OF THE TEN
MILLION WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
SUPPORT THE CITY OF CHICO AND
THE CITY OF OR BILLS REQUESTS.
TO ADDRESS THE CAMPFIRES IMPACTS
TO HOUSING PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE CITY TO
GO IN THE CITY OF ORVILLE TO
DETERMINE FUNDING GAPS.
AND AND THEIR NEEDS AS A RESULT
THE CAMP FIRE -- ONE THING TO
NOTE THAT NONE OF THE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDS HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED AND THAT THIS TIME TO
BE GLAD TO TAKE IN YOUR
QUESTIONS.
NEW THIS MODEL IS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
WE SEE THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN PROPERTY TAX BACK
FILL AS PRIMARILY A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT ON RACE ISSUES.
BUT DO NOTE THAT IT RAISES HER
BROADER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
STATE'S ROLE IN ASSISTING
RECOVERING COMMUNITIES -- THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE DISCRETION IN
THIS AREA AND WILL LIKELY
CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH HIS
DECISION IN THE EVENT OF FUTURE
DISASTERS INTO THE POLICY
CHOICES INVOLVED THERE.
INCLUDE WHAT TYPE OF ASSISTANCE
TO PROVIDE FOR WHAT DURATION AND
AND WHAT AMOUNT.
ON THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CAMPFIRE WILL JUST KNOW THAT
THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY LACKS DETAIL AND SO
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENGAGE THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THINGS LIKE.
EXACTLY WHAT THE ALLOCATIONS
WILL BE WHAT ARE THE SPECS
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES AND EXPECTED
OUTCOMES AND HOW THE USE OF
THOSE FUNDS WILL BE MONITORED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
PUBLIC COME ON THIS ITEM.
WE'RE STILL VERY LENGTHY AGENDA
SO BREVITY WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
JEFF NEAL WITH SEIZE ACT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SEARCH OUR MEMBERS JEAN HEARST
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
BUTTE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE MINISTRATIONS I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DAVID JONES OF HALF THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA ONE OF THE AGENCIES
IT HAS GOT A BETTER QUESTION THE
OTHER SIDE FOR TWELVE POINT NINE
MILLION FOR THE THOMAS FIRE WE
STILL HAVE.
A SIGNIFICANT NEED WE'RE SHORT
OF REVENUE WOULD ASK FOR
CONSIDERATION WHEN THE SPIDER
GETS CLOSED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MORRELL HAD NEEDS SADDAM OPEN.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STILL CONTINUING OUT OF ORDER
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ISSUE NUMBER --
EIGHT CALIFORNIA'S COUNCIL
DISPOSITIONS
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED [inaudible]
I AM.
GERMAN COOPER AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SAM BROWN CRAWFORD I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL.
THE COUNCIL IS PRIMARILY A GRANT
MAKING AGENCY WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE
ACCESSIBILITY OF OUR PROGRAMS TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THE SENSIBILITY STATEWIDE IS
ACCOMPLISHED BY THE FOLLOWING
STAFF WORK TARGETED REGIONAL
OUTREACH WORKSHOPS COMMUNITY
MEETINGS WEBINARS MONITORING THE
GRANT MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT OF GRANT GUIDELINES
CONTINUALLY EVALUATION.
OF OUR WORK OUT IN THE FIELD.
PANEL EDUCATION AND THE COUNCIL
APPROVAL PROCESS.
THE C. A. C. IS REQUESTING AN
ADDITIONAL POSITION AUTHORITY OF
SIX POINT THREE POSITIONS. TO
SUPPORT THE DISTRIBUTION OF
LOCAL ASSISTANCE FUNDS VIA OUR
GRANTING PROGRAMS SINCE THE
AGENCIES DEVASTATING CUTS OVER A
DECADE AGO.
THE C. A. C. IS BEEN FUNCTIONING
AT A DEFICIT IN HUMAN RESOURCES.
PRESENTLY THE C. A. C. IS BEEN
OPERATING WITH A STAFF OF TWENTY
THREE POINT FIVE FTP POSITIONS
ADMINISTERING LOCAL ASSISTANCE
TOTALING FIFTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION ANNUALLY.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED
AN ADDITIONAL ON GOING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE C. AC
BUDGET IN THE FISCAL YEAR.
200-019-2000 TWENTY THIS
ARGUMENT EQUATES TO A 60%
INCREASE IN OUR GRANTING
FUNCTIONS.
WITH LOCAL ASSISTANCE AT
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX MILLION
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL POSITION
AUTHORITY THESE SEE AC WILL ONLY
HAVE TWENTY THREE POINT FIVE FTE
POSITIONS TO ADMINISTER THE
TWENTY SIX MILLION. TO
ILLUSTRATE THIS POINT IT'S
HELPFUL TO LOOK AT THE BUDGET
AND STAFFING IN 200-012-0002
WHEN LOCAL ASSISTANCE WAS
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX MILLION
AND WE HAD FORTY FOUR POINT
SEVEN F. T..
POSITIONS.
PLEASE SEE THE WORKFORCE
ANALYSIS AS THE AGENCY'S BUDGET
HAS INCREMENTALLY INCREASED FROM
ONE MILLION TO FIFTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION.
AND IN AN EFFORT TO MOVE TOWARDS
SERVING THE GEOGRAPHIC AND
CULTURAL DIVERSITY OF THE STATE
CA SEE NOW ADMINISTERS EIGHTEEN
GRANT PROGRAMS.
SERVING APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
HUNDRED ARTS ORGANIZATIONS.
THESE EIGHT HUNDRED ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENT A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE ELEVEN THOUSAND
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
ALMOST.
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED GRANTS WERE
ADMINISTERED THIS YEAR WITH
CURRENT STAFF ALREADY OVER
CAPACITY.
AND THAT THERE IS A NEED TO PASS
ON ACCESSORY DUTIES TO COMPLETE
THE KEY FUNCTIONS NECESSARY IN
THE GRANT DEVELOPMENT PROCESS.
AND PROVIDE THE OUT REACH IT'S
EXPECTED OF A STATE ARTS AGENCY.
THE AGENCY HAS A LIMITED AMOUNT
OF APPROVED POSITIONS AND AN
INCREASE BUDGETARY AUTHORITY
WHICH HAS RESULTED IN INCREASED
TECHNICAL ANALYTICAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE NEEDS TO SUPPORT
THE GROWTH OF AGENCIES PROGRAMS.
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
INCLUDED AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION DOLLARS THE FINANCE
LETTER INDICATES THAT THE C. A.
C. WILL JUST TRIBUTE FIVE
MILLION TO THE ARMENIAN AMERICAN
MUSEUM AND FIVE MILLION TO THE
LOS ANGELES MUSEUM OF THE
HOLOCAUST.
MAKING OUR LOCAL ASSISTANCE
BUDGET THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE 5% PROVISION IS RESTRICTED
TO THE FIRST TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR OUR POSITIONS YOU HAVE
PACKETS IN FRONT OF YOU WITH
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT.
YOU KNOW OUR AGENCIES LOCAL
ASSISTANCE.
VERSES THE AUTHORIZED POSITIONS
AND A CHART OF THE WORKLOAD
MEASURES OVER TIME.
OKAY ASSISTANCE SHE WENT INTO
NIHIL COLORADO -- EIGHT NINE
TOGETHER -- YOU MENTION IT GOT
60% INCREASE IN GRANTS -- WE'RE
THOSE GRANTS GO.
TO NOW THAT 60% INCREASE.
IN A 60% INCREASE IN GRANTS ERA
THAT THEY'LL BE SPREAD OUT
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE SAME TYPES OF GRANT
MAKING -- STRATEGIES THAT WE USE
ALREADY. TWO LOCAL -- ARTS
AGENCIES SO THAT THEY THERE IS
REGIONAL DEVELOPMENT OF ARTS AND
CULTURE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
EVEN IF I WERE THESE GRANTS ARE
USED IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
I IDENTIFY THAT OUT YEAH. FIVE
YOU CAN'T TODAY I MEAN I WILL IT
CAN BE LIKE TO SEE WHERE.
THAT MONEY IS ACTUALLY GUY WOULD
LOVE ENTRIES THAT YOU WERE THE
REPORTED WHERE IT'S USED TO
DISADVANTAGING -- COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF OUR
MISSIONS IS TO SUPPORT
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GREAT [inaudible]
LL.
HI CHRISTINE WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE HAVE A VERY
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WE DEFINITELY
CAN KERR THOUGH WITH THE STAFF
COMMENT THAT -- IT WOULD BE
PREFERABLE TO HAVE A B. C. P.
THAT WOULD BE A PREFERRED METHOD
THE SET UP PROPOSAL DIDN'T COME
WITH ONE SO THAT WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
FINANCE.
CHARLIE MANNING DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
PROPOSAL INCLUDED A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE TO THE C. AC
BUDGET AND A PROVISION A CHANCE
FOR UP 25%.
OF THE TEN MILLION TO OPERATIONS
UNFORTUNATELY POSITIONS WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THAT PROPOSAL AND
THE POSITIONS PROPOSES IN THE
MAY REVISION ALLOW US TO UTILIZE
THE ADMINISTRATION FUNDING
PROVIDED WITH THE ON GOING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
SEOUL WHILE THERE WASN'T A AND
B. C. P. FOR THE SIX POINT THREE
POSITIONS IT IS LINKED TO THE B.
C. P. PROVIDED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- THE STAFF REPORT TALKS
ABOUT A 45% INCREASE IN STAFFING
HELLO KNOWS RIGHT AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE I I KNOW YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER SOME STAFFING SHORTAGES
BUT JEFF IN A FORTY FIVE AT WE
QUALIFY THAT.
HOW DO WE?
SO IT THIS IS SOMETHING WE THINK
ABOUT CAREFULLY AS WE MOVED HER
WORK THROUGHOUT THE DIFFERENT
SEASONS OF OUR WORK.
AND WE DO CAREFUL ANALYSIS AND
EVALUATION OF WHERE THE
STRESSORS ARE CURRENTLY IN OUR
STAFF.
AND HOW CAN WE ACCOMMODATE THOSE
STRESSORS SO WE CAN SERVE THE
FIELD IN THE BEST MANNER.
WE ARE ALSO IN THE MIDST OF IT
AT A TWO YEAR EVALUATION OF OUR
EFFECTIVENESS IN THE FIELD OVER
ALSO WE CAN.
HAVE LOOK AT WHERE ARE GAPS ARE.
AND WHERE OUR SUCCESSES ARE AND
DO EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
FINANCE YOU SPEAK ON THAT ON THE
45% INCREASE -- YEAH I THINK --
OVERALL -- AS THE AND ALSO
WHETHER WAS IN THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL.
SO YEAH IT DUE TO TIMING -- OF
ADDING THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
THE POSITIONS WERE NOT INCLUDED
THE FOR THE NAY REVISION FINANCE
LETTER INCLUDED FOR THESE SIX
POSITIONS WHICH ARE SUPPOSED TO
USE THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNDING THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- AND SO I
GUESS IT WENT OUT ALL WE'RE
TRYING TO ARTICULATE HERE'S THAT
FUNCTIONALLY THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF ONGOING FUNDING HAS
BEEN -- JUSTIFIED THROUGH THE B.
C. P. PROCESS THESE POSITIONS
WILL ALLOW US TO ACTUALLY
ADMINISTER THAT SO -- I AGREE I
AGREE IT'S A LARGE INCREASE BUT
SO IS THE TOTAL ON GOING FUNDING --
AND I THINK -- THE COMMISSION
SORT OF ARTICULATED IN THE PAST
WHEN IT HAD -- GRANT BECAUSE OF
ABOUT TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
THEIR POSITION AUTHORITY WAS
MUCH HIGHER WAS ABOUT FORTY FIVE
POSITIONS SO EVEN THIS IS STILL
ARE LOWER THAN IN PAST.
THE FROM RON POSITIONS WERE
JUSTIFIED THE BEEF IN THE BCP
CORRECT.
YES THAT WE ARE AT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO PROVIDE INFORMATION TO
STAFF IN THE L. L. AT A HIGHER
LEVEL ABOUT WHY WE NEED THE SIX
POSITIONS AND DEFINITELY NOT
THAT TRADITIONAL POP BUT
DEFINITELY TRYING TO PUT
EVERYTHING OUT THERE THAT WE CAN
TO HELP YOU ALL UNDERSTAND THE
NEED. FOR THOSE SUCH RECENTLY
BEEN DONE SEPARATELY KERR IS
THAT ALSO CORRECT.
TRADITIONALLY BEEN DONE
SEPARATELY -- I CAN'T SPEAK I
GUESS TRADITIONALLY TO THAT BUT
AN INCREASE THE BILL BUDGET
ALLOCATION SEPARATE POSITIONS.
I THINK YOU I THINK.
TYPICAL PRACTICE WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE LINK THE SIX POSITIONS IN
THE JANUARY TEN PROPOSAL --
UNFORTUNATELY LIKE I SAID DUE TO
TIMING ISSUES THAT CAN TAKE
PLACE O -- THE NAY REVISION
PART FINANCE LETTER MAKES THE
REQUEST FOR THE SIX POSITIONS
THAT UTILIZES THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WAS
PROVIDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AGAIN.
APOLOGIES FOR THE SORT OF LACK
OF CLARITY AND THE YOU KNOW SORT
OF PROCESS VIOLATION HERE BUT
ESSENTIALLY THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THANK YOU.
QUESTION COMMITTEE THE SERVICE
AREA.
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MISTER
CHAIR -- I THINK I THINK THE
DIRECTOR WAS UNDER SELLING HER
PROGRAM A LITTLE BIT -- BECAUSE
JUST ABOUT THREE OR FOUR YEARS
AGO WE HAD APPROVED A FUNDING I
THINK BETWEEN FIVE TO EIGHT
MILLION CAN'T REMEMBER NOW.
THAT WENT DIRECTLY TO PRISONS
AND TO HELPING WITH -- ENHANCING
PART PROGRAMS AND SOME OF OUR
STATE PRISONS SO UP I'D LOVE TO
ALSO HERE LITTLE BIT OF THE
OUTCOME OF THAT BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT HERE WAS.
A GREAT SUCCESS WHEN THE PROGRAM
HAD BEEN IN PLACE.
UP UNTIL THE TIME BUT WHEN WE
EXPANDED THE DOLLARS.
SO JUST WANTED TO SPEAK TO THE
FACT THAT I THINK -- ARTS
COUNCIL HAS COME A LONG WAY
SINCE.
THE FIVE MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
THAT HIT IT HAD BEEN KIND OF
HELD AT OF ONLY ONE MILLION OF
IT BEING GENERAL FUND AND THE
REMAINING OF IT BEING FROM ANY
AND THE LICENSE PROGRAM SO IT'S
NICE TO SEE.
THE INCREMENTAL PROGRESS I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE DAY WHEN
WE CELEBRATE THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION MARKER -- SET OUT SOME
TIME AGO -- AND WHILE ALSO THIS
IS BEING SAID I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT -- THE FUNDING.
TO THE HOLOCAUST MUSEUM AS WELL
AS TO THE ARMENIAN MUSEUM IS NOW
BEING PLACE THAN NOT JUST
THROUGH LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS BUT
THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
DIRECTLY AND RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE.
OF OF NOT ONLY THE CULTURAL
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE BUT ALSO
OF HIGHLIGHTING.
CERTAIN CULTURES -- THAT WILL
BETTER RELATE TO TRAUMA AND
CHALLENGES WITH THE WITH OTHER
CULTURES IN CALIFORNIA -- I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING.
OF THIS GOING FORWARD GIVEN
ESPECIALLY THE PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF FINDINGS OF ARE
BEING HANDLED IN A WAY WHERE.
AS CONSTRUCTION OR AS PROJECT.
OF BENCHMARKS ARE MET THE
FUNDING IS RELEASED I'M I'M
ASSUMING THAT THAT'S THE CASE I
WANTED TO VERIFY.
WELL -- SO WE DO NOT DIRECTLY
REQUEST A TEN MILLION DOLLARS
AND FOR THE CONSTRUCTION.
PROJECTS IS A LITTLE OUTSIDE OF
SENATE OPERATING -- PROCEDURE IT
A FOR FOR ME I UNDERSTAND AND
RESPECT THE PRIORITY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AND SO IT STILL IS A LITTLE
CONFUSING TO ME AT THIS POINT
BUT WE'RE GETTING CLARITY AS WE
MOVE ALONG.
AND THANK YOU FOR MENTIONING --
OUR WORK IN THE PRISONS WE WE
HAVE -- ARTS PROGRAMMING
PRESENTLY AND EVERY PUBLIC.
I HAVE A CELL ATTY YEAH -- FOR
ADULTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN THAT WE ARE PUTTING -- ARTS
COUNCIL IN CONTACT WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY THAT
HAD PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED THIS
FUNDING SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE
SOME TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ABOUT
HOW THESE -- FUNDS ARE TYPICALLY
MOVE TO MUSEUMS ARE HOW THAT
HAPPENED IN THE PAST SO OKAY I
THINK THE BENCHMARKS WOULD BE
VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE GOING TO OPEN UP
PUBLIC COMMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MY NAME
IS JULIE BAKER I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA ARTS
ADVOCATES -- AND WOULD ALSO LOVE
TO SEE AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NECESSARY AND MENTIONED WOULD
LOVE TO SEE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
AS THE MARKER AS WELL -- AND WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR THE ARTS AND
CREATIVE SECTORS IN CALIFORNIA
THE BUREAU OF ECONOMIC ANALYSIS.
STATES THAT -- THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY IS SEVEN POINT 1% OF
CALIFORNIA'S GROSS STATE PRODUCT
THAT'S AHEAD OF AGRICULTURE AND
TRANSPORTATION SO WE DEFINITELY
SEE THAT THIS INVESTMENT THAT
YOU MAKE IN THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL AND HAVING THE ARTS BE
ACCEPTABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
IN OUR ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA AND
IN JOBS -- I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT OPPOSE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S LINE ITEMS
FOR THE LOS ANGELES MUSEUM -- OF
THE HOLOCAUST AND THE ARMENIAN
AMERICAN MUSEUM.
IN OUR IN SUPPORT ALL FUNDING
THAT GOES TOWARDS THE ARTS WE%
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATION GOING THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCILS BUDGET.
SEE SEE DOES NOT FUND CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS AND IS ACTUALLY
FOR BID IN UNDER THE CURRENT
REGULATIONS.
IN ADDITION THIS PROPOSED PASSED
THROUGH ALLOCATION IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE CA SEES
MISSION.
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL IS
THE GRANT MAKING ARM OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THEIR
MODEL IS TO PROVIDE FOR A FAIR
AND COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS
THAT IT HERE'S TO THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS.
THE C. A. C. FUNDS COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AT LEVELS FAR
BELOW WHAT IS ANTICIPATED BY
THESE TWO LARGE APPROPRIATIONS
WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY SUBMIT
THAT THIS FUNDING WILL BE BE
MORE PROPERLY PASSED THROUGH TO
THESE MUSEUMS BE THE CALIFORNIA
MUSEUM GRANT PROGRAM.
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
NATURAL RESOURCES CREATED IN
TURN TWENTY THIRTEEN WHEN
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN SIGNED A
BEFORE YOU.
TO CALIFORNIA MUSEUM GRANT
PROGRAM IS AN OBJECTIVELY BETTER
MECHANISM FOR EXECUTING THIS
FUNDING SHOULD ALLEGE THAT
LEGISLATOR VOTE TO DO SO.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID JONES
ABOUT THE CITY OF GLENDALE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
ARMENIAN MUSEUM FUNDING WE THINK
IT'S A OF OF IMPORTANT CULTURAL
AMENITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AS I SAID EARLIER
THOSE ARE ITEMS.
EIGHT NINE BILLS WILL BE HELD
OPEN. FOR SIX OR LESS AGENDA
ITEM ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN CANNABIS.
THANK YOU THANK [inaudible]
IS THERE.
I'M ACTUALLY.
YEAH.
I CLING COME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M HERE TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CANNABIS TAX BOND PACKAGE -- AS
APPROVED IN PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR EXCISE TAXES ARE LEVIED ON
THE CULTIVATION AND RETAIL SALES
BOTH ADULT USE A MEDICINAL
CANNABIS.
WITH TAX REVENUES BEING
DEPOSITED INTO THE CANNABIS TAX
FUND.
THEY CANNABIS TAX -- CANNABIS
EXCISE TAX IS FORECAST TO
GENERATE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS AN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY I REDUCTION FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT IN
THE NEAR TERM REVENUE ESTIMATES
WILL BE SUBJECT TO SIGNIFICANT
UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE THE MARKET
HAS ONLY RECENTLY BEEN
ESTABLISHED.
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR ALSO
SPECIFY THE ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES IN THE CANNABIS TAX
FUND.
WHICH ARE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED IN PRIORITIZED AS
FOLLOWS ALLOCATION.
ONE GOES TO REGULATORY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS NECESSARY
TO IMPLEMENT THE CANNABIS ACT.
THEY CANNABIS PACKAGE INCLUDES
FIFTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ASSIST IN
THE CREATION AND ADMINISTRATION
OF EQUITY PROGRAMS.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL ADMINISTER THE
GRANT PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF THE
BUREAU CANNABIS CONTROL.
ALLOCATION TO GOES TO RESEARCH
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE
LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS AND THE
PAST EFFECTS OF ITS
CRIMINALIZATION.
THE PACKAGE DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY
CHANGES TO ALLOCATION TO
PROGRAMS.
AND THEN FINALLY ALLOCATION
THREE IS THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY WILL HAVE
EXPENDITURES MADE FROM THIS
PORTION OF THE TAX FUND
ALLOCATIONS.
WE EXPECT THAT A HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR
THESE ACTIVITIES HOWEVER WE
WOULD KNOW THAT THAT'LL ACTUALLY
BE DEPENDENT ON THE FINAL -- TWO
TAX RECEIPTS THAT ARE RECEIVED --
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SO I'LL GO
THROUGH AND KINDA DELINEATE
THERE'S THERE'S THREE MAIN
COMPONENTS THEIR 60% TO
EDUCATION PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT OF YOU SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
AND AND 20% TO SORT OF RESOURCES
AND ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
AND ILLEGAL.
MISS CULTIVATION AND THEN PUBLIC
SAFETY PROGRAMS.
SO THE FIRST 60% WE ESTIMATE
RIGHT NOW TO BE A HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE FIRST TWELVE MILLION WILL GO
TO THE PARK MAP HEALTHCARE
CANNABIS SURVEILLANCE AND
EDUCATION ACTIVITIES.
AND THEN THE REMAINING TWENTY
FIVE OR 75% WHICH WE ESTIMATED
EIGHTY POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WILL GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
SUBSIDIZE CHILDCARE FOR INCOME
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES TO KEEP THOSE
CHILDREN OCCUPIED IN ENGAGED.
IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT THAT'S
DISCOURAGING POTENTIAL USE OF
SUBSTANCES.
THE REMAINING 20% WILL GO TO
TWENTY WHICH WE ESTIMATE AT
TWENTY ONE POINT FIVE MILLIONTO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR COMPETITIVE GRANTS
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT.
YOUTH PROGRAMS IN THE AREAS OF
EDUCATION PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS.
WITH THE REMAINING 5% OR FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY ACCESS GRANTS.
FROM THE DIP A CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY.
THESE GRANTS WILL FUND PROGRAMS
TO SUPPORT.
A YOUTH ACCESS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES OR QUOTE AND CULTURAL
RESOURCES.
SO NOW WE GET INTO THE 20% WHICH
WE ESTIMATE AT THIRTY NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION FOR CLEAN UP
REMEDIATION ENFORCEMENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS CREATED BY
A LEGAL CANNABIS CULTIVATION
ILLEGAL CANNABIS CULTIVATION
EXCUSE ME.
TIMES 60% OR TWENTY NINE OR
TWENTY THREE POINT NINE MILLION
WILL GO TO THE PART OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
OF WHICH THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION WILL GO TO SUPPORT CLEAN
AFTER MEDIATION RESTORATION
EFFORTS AND TEN POINT ONE
MILLION WILL GO TO ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS.
THE OTHER 40% -- WORK FIFTEEN
POINT NINE MILLION WILL GO TO
PARTS OF WHICH SEVEN POINT ONE
MILLION WILL BE USED TO SURVEY
THE IMPACTS AND IDENTIFY -- I
KNOWN AREAS OF CANNABIS
CULTIVATION TO ASSIST IN
PRIORITIZING FUTURE.
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION PERMIT REMEDIATION
AND RESTORATION OF CULT OF
ILLEGAL CULTIVATION ACTIVITIES
ON STATE PARK LAND AND THREE
POINT TWO MILLION TO MAKE ROADS.
AND TRAILS ACCESSIBLE FOR PEACE
OFFICER PATROLLING
IDENTIFICATION OF ILLEGAL ON
CANNABIS CULTIVATION.
AND THEN THIS TAKES US TO OUR
TWENTY PERSON OUR FINAL 20%
AGAIN ESTIMATED AT THIRTY NINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY RELATED ACTIVITIES.
TWO POINT SIX MILLION WILL GO TO
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
FOR TRAINING RESEARCH AND POLICY
DEVELOPMENT REALLY TO IMPAIR
DRIVING.
AND FOR ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT.
THE REMAINING 30% ESTIMATED
ELEVEN POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
TO AS C. H. P. FOR IMPAIRED
DRIVING IN TRAFFIC SAFETY GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT WILL GO TO NON
PROFITS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS
AUTHORIZED IN PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR AND THE REMAINING 70%
ESTIMATED AT ABOUT TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE BOARD
STATE COMMUNITY ORRECTIONS FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE NOT
BANNED CANNABIS CULTIVATION OR
RETAIL ACTIVITIES.
HELLO HEARD PRIORITIZE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS FOCUSED ON
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION%
PROGRAMS FOR YOUTH AND TO
SUPPORT COLLABORATIVE
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS AIMED AT
COMBATING.
ILLEGAL CANNABIS CULTIVATION IN
SALES -- AS I NOTED THESE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS ARE SUBJECT TO CHANGE
CHANGE ACTUALLY BE DEPENDENT ON
THE FINAL TWO QUARTER.
FINAL TWO PAYMENTS OF EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND FINALLY THE MAY
REVISION ALSO ACTUALLY INCLUDES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE RELATED.
TO CAMPUS RELATED ACTIVITIES.
THERE'S TECHNICAL CLEANUP
RELATED TO THE CANNABIS CONTROL
APPEALS PANEL STATUE.
STREAMLINING PROVISIONAL LICENSE
IS ENHANCING EQUITY GRANT
PROGRAM AND STRENGTHENING IN A
MID ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES FOR
UNLICENSED CAME BACK.
CANNABIS ACTIVITY AND EXTENDING
THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION.
THIS CONCLUDES MY LONG COMMENTS
HERE AND I'LL DO MY BEST TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS BUT OBVIOUSLY
THESE ARE SORT OF BROAD REACHING
AND IF I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
I'LL GET BACK TO YOU THE U. L.
L..
HOW INCREASING AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
PREPARED -- SHORTHAND OUT -- IF
YOU DON'T HAVE ONE UNFORTUNATELY
I APOLOGIZE IS PASSED OUT A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER SO IF YOU
DON'T HAVE ONE I THINK THAT
SURGEONS HAVE A FEW EXTRA COPIES.
I'M.
OKAY GREAT -- SO I'M GONNA SKIP
OVER THE FIRST TWO PAGES BECAUSE
I BELIEVE THOSE WERE -- VERY
WELL COVERED BY -- BY FINANCE BY --
MISTER COLLINS SO IF YOU TURN TO
PAGE -- THREE I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE'S A TABLE
THAT VISUALLY SHOWS -- WHAT
FINANCE EXPLAINS IN TERMS OF
WHAT -- IS GOING TO BE ALLOCATED
TO EACH PROGRAM EACH ALLOCATION
AND HOW MUCH THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
FOR EACH ALLOCATION.
I'M JUST A COUPLE THINGS AS WELL
TO HIGHLIGHT -- TO REINFORCE
WHAT FINANCE MENTIONED -- BED
ONLY SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
ALLOCATION ONE IS THAT NOW
THEY'RE PROPOSING SOME FUNDING --
THROUGH THE FEAR OF CAMPUS
CONTROL TO GO BAD AS A FOREIGN
EQUITY PROGRAM PREVIOUSLY THAT
WAS FUNDED OUT OF THE GENERAL
FUND -- YOU'LL ALSO NOTE THAT
THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR -- AS
WITH SAID AS WAS STATED
PROVOCATION THREE SO THIS IS AB
AND IMPORTANT HERE BECAUSE THIS
IS REALLY THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
HAD.
FUNS THAT ARE GOING TO ALL OF
THOSE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES -- IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR WE BEGIN
OUR ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION WE HIGHLIGHT A FEW
FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONSIDERATION.
THE FIRST ISSUE WE WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THIS
EXPENDITURE PLAN REALLY REFLECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PRIORITIES -- SO --
PROP SIXTY FOUR PROVIDED
ACTUALLY QUITE A BIT OF A BRAT
IN TERMS OF THE FLEXIBILITY
PROVIDED THE ADMINISTRATION --
TO USE THESE FUNDS FOR A VARIETY
OF ACTIVITIES AND SO REALLY THE
EXPENDITURE PLAN REFLECTS THOSE
PRIORITIES -- IT'S ALSO AS WAS
MENTIONED BASED ON THOSE REVENUE
SO IT SAID SUBJECT TO CHANGE --
THE SECOND POINT WE WANTED TO
MAKE IS THAT IN GENERAL IT DOES
THE EXPENDITURE PLAN DOES SEEM
CONSISTENT WITH PROP -- SIXTY
FOUR WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT IN A
COUPLE PLACES THERE'S THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A LACK OF CLARITY
IN PROP SIXTY FOUR AND SO THERE
THERE COULD BE A A LESS
CERTAINTY -- AND JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THOSE ONE
IS THE USE OF THAT ALLOCATION
ONE FOR EQUITY PROGRAMS -- ALSO
THE USE OF ALLOCATION THREE FOR
CHILDCARE SLOTS THE PENDING ON
HOW THAT'S DONE -- COULD BE SOME
LEGAL UNCERTAINTY THERE.
THE THIRD ISSUE WE WANTED TO
RAISE FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION IS REALLY THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE -- THERE'S
SOME UNCERTAINTY REGARDING THAT --
SO CLEARLY PROP SIXTY FOUR
CONTINUOUSLY ALLOCATE THE FUNDS --
SO THE LEGISLATURE DOESN'T HAVE
TO TAKE ACTION TO APPROPRIATE
FUNDS -- BUT THERE'S SOME
UNCERTAINTY EXACT ON EXACTLY HOW
MUCH THE LEGISLATURE CAN DIRECT
THESE FUNDS -- SO THAT'S AN AREA
WHERE THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
GRAY AREA.
I NEXT WEEK WE DID WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT DESPITE THE
UNCERTAINTY IN TERMS OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE IN DIRECTING
THE FUND SPECIFICALLY.
WE THINK THAT CLEARLY THE
LEGISLATURE PLAYS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN OVERSEEING
THESE FUNDS -- AND THIS IS IN A
VERY CONSISTENT THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE IN GENERAL --
BUT ESPECIALLY WITH THESE
FRIENDS GET ESPECIALLY GIVEN SO
MUCH FLEXIBILITY WE THINK IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE -- THEIR FEW
QUESTIONS THAT WE SUGGEST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER AS A CONDUCTOR THIS
OVERSIGHT ROLE -- THE FIRST IS
WHETHER THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROVIDED SUFFICIENT INFORMATION --
TO HELP THE LEGISLATURE MAKE --
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE FUNDS ARE
BEING ALLOCATED IN USE I'M IN
SOME CASES THESE FUNDS ARE
PROPOSED FOR NEW PROGRAMS IN
OTHER CASES VERY.
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSIONS TO
EXISTING PROGRAMS SO THE
LEGISLATURE'S GONNA WANT TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY HOW THEY'RE
GOING ABOUT DOING THIS WHERE THE
FUNDS ARE TO BE ALLOCATED HOW
THE PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO BE RUN.
ON THOSE KINDS OF THINGS SO --
WE THINK THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
I'M ALSO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NEW POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT.
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THESE
FUNDS -- THERE WEREN'T ANY
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS --
PROVIDING DETAILS ON THESE
POSITIONS THE LEGISLATURE'S JUST
GONNA WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
COMFORTABLE BUT IT'S RECEIVED
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO UNDERSTAND
THE NEED FOR THESE POSITIONS
WHAT THEY'LL BE DOING -- AND
REALLY AND REALLY OVERSEE THOSE.
IN CASES WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE IT HAS
SUFFICIENT INFORMATION WE THINK
IT'S CERTAINLY APPROPRIATE FOR
THAT.
LEGISLATURE TO ASK DEPARTMENTS
TO COME FORWARD IN BUDGET
HEARING SUCH AS THIS ONE NOT TO
PROVIDE THAT KIND OF INFORMATION.
THE NEXT MAJOR AREA OF FORGET WE
THINK THE LEGISLATURE REALLY CAN
OVERSEE IS IS ON OUTCOMES.
SO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER --
ASKING THE ADMINISTRATION WHAT
ITS OUTCOMES WHAT OUTCOMES
EXPECTS TO TO ACHIEVE -- AND
WHAT ITS TARGETS ARE FOR THE USE
OF THESE FUNDS THIS YEAR WE HAVE
A COUPLE OF HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ALLOCATION.
THREE IN FUTURE YEARS IT COULD
BE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN NOT
BECAUSE IT COULD GROW OVER TIME
AND SO THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT OUT
OF MONEY -- WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE CHEATING THE OUTCOMES THAT --
BIRD WE KNOW WHAT THE WHAT
OUTCOMES WERE SHOOTING -- FOR
AND THEREFORE CAN HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ACHIEVING THEM -- SO AGAIN -- IN
CASES WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T ADEQUATELY IDENTIFIED
OUTCOME THE LEGISLATURE COULD
ADOPT REPORTING LANGUAGE TO
REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION TO TO
PROVIDE THOSE OUTCOME MEASURES
OR IT COULD PROVIDE SOME
LEGISLATIVE INTENSE -- AND THEN
FINALLY WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HOW THOSE
OUTCOMES THE ACHIEVEMENT OF
THOSE OUTCOMES IT'S GOING TO BE
MONITORED ON AN ONGOING BASIS --
AND THAT COULD BE FOR EXAMPLE
SOME REPORTING LANGUAGE I THAT
WOULD GIVE THE LEGISLATURE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON WHERE
MONIES SPENT -- WHAT OUTCOMES
ARE ACHIEVED I'D SAY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS ABLE TO HAVE SOME
OVERSIGHT OVER THESE FUNDS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS?
THANK YOU THAT'S A QUESTION FOR
FINANCE -- THE 60% THE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
TROUBLE IS TO DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR CANNABIS SURVEILLANCE
WHAT IS CAN THE SURVEILLANCE --
WE'RE ACTUALLY WORKING ON A
RESPONSE FOR STAFF TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE IN DEPTH BUT
GENERALLY MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH -- SORT OF I
DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE A
REPRESENTED HERE THAT WANTS --
TO FOR RESPOND BUT GENERALLY
THEY LOOK AT SORT OF METRICS IN
THE COMMUNITY AND SORT OF A TAN
THOSE TO MONITOR HEALTH --
FACTORS IN THE POPULATION SO
THAT THAT YOU CAN IDENTIFY WHERE
TO INVEST EDUCATION OR
ADDITIONAL TREATMENT OR
PREVENTION RESOURCES SO -- I
DON'T KNOW IF I KIND OF GOT THAT
RIGHT AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL THAT --
YOU CAN JUMP IN IF I MISSED
ANYTHING SURE SURE HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M TRICIA BLOCK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH -- WE'RE
REQUESTING TWELVE MILLION AND
FIFTEEN POSITIONS FROM THE
EDUCATION PREVENTION AND YOUTH
FUND FOR SURVEILLANCE AND
EDUCATION -- CANNABIS
SURVEILLANCE WILL ALLOW US TO
IDENTIFY ANTICIPATED AND ON
ANTICIPATED EFFECTS OF CANNABIS
LEGALIZATION AND IT MAY ALSO
HELP US.
IDENTIFY EMERGING TRENDS THAT
COULD AFFECT THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH --
WITH THE ROBUST DATA COLLECTION
WILL ALSO BE ABLE TO BETTER
TARGET ARE EDUCATION AND
MESSAGING CAMPAIGNS.
WE WOULD BE BUILDING AND
DEVELOPING OUR THE ARCHITECTURE
THAT WILL LINK MULTIPLE DATA
SYSTEMS TOGETHER LIKE POISON
CONTROL.
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS EMS --
THE RETAIL MARKET PLACE AND MANY
OTHERS.
AT THAT SYSTEM WILL BE A HUB
THAT WILL PULL THE DATA SOURCES
TOGETHER AND I WE CAN IDENTIFY
THE DATA IN NEAR REAL TIME --
INITIALLY WILL BE WORKING ON
DATA USE AGREEMENTS AND
DEVELOPING THE SOFTWARE THAT
WILL LINK EACH SOURCE AND WILL
ALSO BE PURCHASING QUESTIONS
FROM THE ON GOING SURVEY TOOLS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO US THANK
YOU SO AND I I MEMORY IN THE
REST OF THIS AND THE SENATE 5%
220%.
IN ITS THIS IS ALL CHILDREN 35%
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. 20% NEW
YOUTH PROGRAMS THE FOUR
REMAINING 5% YOUTH ACCESS SO
WEIRD IT'S A HUNDRED NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
THEY'RE DEFYING PROBLEMS WITH
OUR YOUTH AND DRUG USE WITH
CANNABIS.
SO THAT THAT'S A BIG ISSUE AND
THAT'S THAT'S A BIG CONCERN OF
MINE -- AT ANY IS ALSO
INTERESTING IF YOUR READING THIS.
I'M GOING TO THE THE THIRTY NINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION OBVIOUSLY
FOR C. H. B. -- PEOPLE DRIVING
IMPAIRED -- AND THEN GRANT
PROBLEMS PROGRAM FOR NONPROFITS.
BUT WAS VERY INTERESTING IS A
70% A TWENTY SIX MILLION IS
GOING TO CITIES.
THAT -- LEGALIZE THERE HAVE
CANNABIS SO OUT OF CALIFORNIA'S
FOR IN SOME CITIES.
HOW MANY CITIES LEGALIZE
CANNABIS?
SO YOU WERE TALKING TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS 30% OF THIS
FUNDING.
IS GOING TO SEE THAT LEGALIZED
IT.
THE FIRST AND SECOND -- COUNTY
LEAST JUST TO SEE SACRAMENTO
THAT LEGALIZED IT YOU'VE GOT I
THINK SIX OTHER.
LOCAL CITIES IN JURISDICTIONS
THAT [inaudible]
BENNETT SO.
HOW HOW DO WE -- AND I'M WHEN I
LOOK.
NUMBER ONE WAS NUMBER SEASON
CALIFORNIA ALLOW CANNABIS CELLS
ARE CULTIVATION -- THE THE
LATEST NUMBER I THINK THAT'S
ALWAYS CHANGING SO IT'S A MOVING
TARGET BUT I THINK I THE NUMBER
OF BANDS CITIES IS AROUND THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY AND I BELIEVE
THERE'S FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
CITY STATEWIDE SO.
SO I GUESS AND AND I'M I WORKED
WITH THE CANNABIS FOLKS SO WE'RE
NOT AT ODDS BUT THAT'S A BIG
CHUNK OF MONEY.
JUST GOING TO CITIES.
THAT ALLOW.
CANNABIS SALES AND DISTRIBUTION.
THAT'S 7% OF THAT PLOT SO SO
THAT THAT.
THAT REQUIREMENT WAS ACTUALLY
SPECIFIED IN PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR THAT I HAD TO GO TO
JURISDICTIONS CORRECT THAT HAVE
A GRAND IT SO WE'RE JUST HEARING
TELL THAT THE LEGISLATURE DOES
HAVE A LOT OF LEEWAY I BELIEVE I
I AGREE WITH.
THE LA -- WE DO HAVE -- SOME ON
THAT BECAUSE IT'S A BIG ISSUE
AND AND ONE THING ABOUT THE THE
INDUSTRY AND SOME FOLKS ARE FROM
INDUSTRY.
YOU CAN SIGN ON THIS ISSUE.
AND AT THE END OF THIS THE ISSUE
OF ILLEGAL MARKET EMAIL AND LA I
GUESS THERE.
AT FOR THE AIRPORT.
ILLEGAL INTERNATIONAL.
THEIR SIEGES UP UNDER 66610066%
FOR CANADA SMUGGLING.
SO THE BLACK MARKET THE BIG
ISSUE I SEE MONEY GOING TO
FISHING GAME AND EVERYBODY BUT
WE'RE STILL NOT TALKING THE
BLACK MARKET ISSUE.
AND WHAT'S INTERESTING IS FOR
THAT RESTORATION AND DAMAGE BUT
WE KNOW THAT IN SACRAMENTO AND A
LOT OF AREAS -- MUSCLES HOUSES
ARE INDOOR ROSE THAT ARE OUT
THERE IT'S ORGANIZED CRIME A
FULL FROM BACK EAST -- USING --
IMMIGRANTS. FOR LABOR.
SO AT SOME POINT THE INDUSTRY
WHO ARE HERE.
HAS TO COME OUT AND TAKE A STAND
IF YOU YOU'RE AGAINST A BLACK
MARKET BECAUSE YOU'RE PAYING
TAXES YOU COME OUT THE DARK AND
YOU'RE DOING THAT.
AND THERE'S BEEN PLENTY OF BILLS
WITH INDUSTRY HAS DONE NOTHING.
BUT SIT ON THEIR **** ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING SO SOME PLAY YOU GOT TO
DECIDE.
ARE YOU PART OF PALMER PA THE
SOLUTION.
YOU'RE STILL NOT THE BLACK
MARKET THERE'S NO REASON WHY XIN
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE
BLACK MARKET.
YOU GUYS HAVEN'T DONE THAT TRIED
WORKING WITH YOU AND I'M CALLING
YOU OUT RIGHT NOW YOU DIDN'T YOU
DON'T SQUAT.
SO.
YEAH YEAH.
I'M NOT THIS THIS IS REAL I
TALKED A BUNCH OF FOLKS OUT
THERE ABOUT IT DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE.
YOU KNOW AND IT IS THIS IS
VERONICA.
ALL THIS MONIES TOWARDS OUR KIDS
IN THIS ISSUE SO GET YOUR ACT
TOGETHER.
BECAUSE SOME POINT IT'S NOT
GOING TO MEET TO COME BACK AND
WATCHING THE BUT ON THIS.
HELLO PEOPLE MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
ON THIS BUT YET YOU KNOW THEY
DON'T WANT.
TO YOU KNOW MAKE IT RIGHT SO --
THIS LACKEY YEAH I'VE.
FEW THINGS I'D LIKE TO SAY FIRST
OF ALL I I FINAL CATION THREE TO
BE A LITTLE BIT -- QUESTIONABLE
[inaudible]
WHEN -- SUCH A LARGE PERCENTAGE.
WE'RE TREATING TO DAYCARE.
I MEAN I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
THE NEXUS IS DISCOURAGING
POTENTIAL USE OF CANNABIS I
THINK THAT'S QUITE CREATIVE.
WAS IT A LOT THIS QUESTION THOSE
THAT WRITTEN IN THE PROCESS
BEFORE LANGUAGE IS THAT
SOMETHING POLITICIANS PUT IN
THERE.
NO IT WAS NOT SO YEAH.
AND THAT IS 60% CAN GO TO
PROGRAMS THAT EMPHASIZE
EDUCATION AND PENSION EARLY
INTERVENTION SCHOOL RETENTION IN
TIMELY TREATS ARE TREATMENT
SERVICES FOR YOUTH.
THEIR FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS --
WE DEFINITELY THINK THAT THAT --
CHILD CARE INVESTMENT -- HITS
THE EARLY INTERVENTION IN SCHOOL
RETENTION MARKS -- AND WE DO
THINK IT'S A HIGH PRIORITY NEED
SO WE THINK IT FITS WITHIN THE
INTENT INDEFINITELY IS AN AREA
BUT LITTLE TALK HERE WE'RE NOT
WORRIED ABOUT THEM.
CONSUMING CANNABIS SO.
THEY'RE NOT GET CONSENT IN THE
CANNABIS CONSUMERS LIKE THINK
IT'S AN INCREASE IN CHILDCARE I
THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE.
DISCUSSED IN THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND THEY'RE PROBABLY
MORE BETTER POSITION TO SPEAK TO
THE ELEMENTS OF THOSE
CONNECTIONS BUT I I DO THINK
THAT -- WE BELIEVE THERE'S AN
AXIS.
I DON'T ALTER ANYWAYS I I'D LIKE
TO CONTINUE ALONG THE LINE OF
THE BIGGEST THREAT. TO THIS
INDUSTRY AND TO THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE CLEARLY IS.
WHAT -- THE CHAIR INDICATED AND
THAT IS THE LIST OF MARKET.
AND I SEE ROUTE I AM THANKFUL
FOR THEM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
ALLOTMENT [inaudible]
THAT'S ATTRIBUTED HERE TOWARDS
IMPAIRMENT -- BECAUSE THAT IS
VERY CREDIBLE BECAUSE THAT IS A
LIFE AND DEATH CIRCUMSTANCES.
HOWEVER THE LIFE OF THIS
INDUSTRY.
IS BASICALLY AT STAKE BECAUSE OF
A LACK OF ENGAGEMENT AGAINST THE
ILLICIT MARKET.
AND I DON'T BLAME JUST THE THE
INDUSTRY FOR THAT.
THAT CHALLENGE I THINK THAT
THAT'S PART OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF GOVERNMENT.
AND I THINK WE HAVE.
THIS REALLY -- CONFUSING
CIRCUMSTANCE BETWEEN WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IT IS IT IS IT TO
TAKE ON THE ILLICIT MARKET
WHETHER IT'S LOCALS OR WHETHER
IT'S THE STATE AND ITS WE'VE GOT
THE PROVERBIAL.
FINGER POINTING GOING TOWARDS
EACH OTHER AND NO ONE IS DOING A
DARN THING.
AND IT WOULD HELP TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF SOME OF THIS
FUNDING. TO ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR PROBLEM AGAINST
ILLICIT MARKET I DON'T SEE VERY
MUCH OF THAT. FOR THAT PURPOSE
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS A
DISSERVICE.
AND I THINK IT'S MISDIRECTED.
I I THINK.
IT'S CLEARLY THE BIGGEST THREAT
TO THE TO THE SURVIVAL OF THIS --
REGULATED MARKET -- BECAUSE THE
ILLICIT MARKET HAS HAD A LOT OF
TIME TO BECOME VERY GOOD.
AT DELIVERING THIS PRODUCT
TWENTY YEARS TO BE EXACT PLUS
YEARS AND NO OTHER STATE HAS HAD
THIS CONDITION.
AND SO WE NOT ONLY HAVE THE
LARGEST POPULATION BUT WE HAVE A
VERY SKILLED DELIVERY NETWORK
THAT WE'RE NOT REALLY TAKING ON
SERIOUSLY.
AND I FIND THAT TO BE.
VERY VERY VERY DISAPPOINTING.
AND I THINK IT'S MUCH MORE
POTENT THAN.
THIS WHERE THEY BECAUSE OF DAY
CARE AND I REALLY REALLY HOPE
THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY.
TO GET SOME OF THE FUNDS TO GET
THE COORDINATED EFFORT TO GO
AGAINST ILLICIT MARKET BECAUSE
THAT IS THE THREAT AS FAR AS THE
FOLKS DOING WITH LISTEN MARKET
IT'S YOUR LOCAL LEVEL.
IS NOT C. H. P..
IT'S NOT A LOT OF YOUR STATE
AGENCIES THAT DEAL WITH THE
RATIFICATION AND DEAL WITH THIS
IS THAT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THAT RUNNING THESE FOLKS SO IT'S
JUST THE PRIORITIES.
IN.
BUT IS THIS WONDER WHO'S DOING
THIS NEWS MAKE THE PLANS OUT
YEAH THERE ARE DISTRICTS SOME
CONSTRAINTS WITH PROP.
SIXTY FOUR WAS ON THIS OTHER
PHONE FUNDING IS JUST -- MIND
BOGGLING SO GO AHEAD OPEN UP
PUBBLICATO MISTER NAZARIAN SORRY.
THANK YOU AND I'M ACTUALLY VERY
GLAD THAT I'M HEARING ALL OF
THIS BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAPPENED THREE YEARS AGO AS
IN THE IN THE CLIMB.
TO OF THE BALLOT PROPOSITION --
WITH.
WHETHER YOU HAVE FOLKS OPPOSING
OR SUPPORTING.
EVERYONE WOULD REST ASSURED THAT
THERE WOULD BE ENOUGH FUNDING
AND REVENUE COMING IN. TO HELP
SUPPORT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE SO DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
BE SUPPORTED TO ENSURE THAT THIS
MARKET IS REGULATED WELL.
AND SOMETHING THAT PROBABLY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN MADE LEGAL MANY
YEARS AGO -- NOW THAT IT'S GONNA
BE LEGALIZED AND THERE'S GONNA
BE A RUSH.
OF OF OF DEMAND COMING IN.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT.
TO UP REGULATE AND OVERSEE AND
PUT IN SYSTEMS IN PLACE QUICKLY
ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO MEET THAT
DEMAND.
AND I THINK WE'RE STILL
STRUGGLING WITH THAT AS WE'RE
GOING FORWARD.
BUT I'M GLAD THAT THE
CONVERSATION THAT COME UP ABOUT.
PRIORITIZING FUNDING FOR SOME OF
THE AREAS THAT -- OF WE WERE SO
COMFORTABLE IN SAYING THAT.
ALL THAT REST ASSURED ALL THAT
WILL BE ADDRESSED -- BUT THAT
WERE NOT REALLY PRIORITIZING
RIGHT NOW THAT'S A THAT'S GOIG
TO BE I THINK AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION ONE THING I WANTED.
TO GO BACK TO WAS JUST THAT THE
SURVEILLANCE COMPONENT IS THERE
ANY DATA THAT YOU CAN SHARE.
THAT YOU'VE BEEN COLLECTING.
AT LEAST IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS WE
HAVE SOME SURVEY QUESTION DATA
WE CAN GET DATA FROM -- POISON
CONTROL THERE'S A THERE'S A
NUMBER OF DATA SOURCES OUT THERE
BUT WE NEED THE THE POSITIONS TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE THAT DATA AND
TURN IT INTO INFORMATION SO THAT --
WE CAN ACT ON IT AND PROVIDED
[inaudible]
OKAY.
DO YOU BUT IF YOU'VE COLLECTED
ANYTHING UP UNTIL NOW.
I WINTERS DEVISE A BASE I'D BE
INTERESTED TO SEE WHAT HOW.
HELLO.
WHERE THINGS ARE HAPPENING AND
WHAT'S GOING ON SO I'D BE VERY
CURIOUS TO SEE THAT? ONE IS WHAT
THIS.
ADDRESS SOMETHING MISTER YEAH I
I I DON'T THINK IT WILL SATISFY
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS BUT I DO
THINK -- FOR TO GET ON THE
RECORD AS FAR AS AS IT RELATES
TO ENFORCEMENT THAT THE CAMPUS
PACKAGE DOES INCLUDE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR ENFORCEMENT RELATED
ACTIVITIES IN THE RESOURCE
ENVIRONMENT ALLOCATION INCLUSIVE
AND THERE'S ABOUT FORTY TWO
SWORN POSITIONS.
AS I HIGHLIGHTED EARLIER THIS
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
THAT THE SEC GRANT PROGRAM WHICH
WILL FUND YOUTH PREVENTION
PROGRAMS BUT IT ALSO WILL FUND A
COLLABORATIVE ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
WERE ASKING TO ESTABLISH
STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR THE
LICENSE AUTHORITIES TO BE ABLE
TO BRING ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES AGAINST UNLICENSED
INDIVIDUALS WHICH DOESN'T EXIST
FOR ALL THEM TODAY -- ALSO
ADMINISTRATIVELY BETWEEN APRIL
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY STATE DEPARTMENTS
THAT HAVE A ROLE IN THE IN
CANNABIS OVERSIGHT WILL -- WILL
ARE PLANNING TO FILL A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY POSITIONS FOR AND
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT
RELATED.
WHICH WILL BRING THE TOTAL
COMPLIANCE ENFORCEMENT RELATED
POSITIONS TO ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO STATEWIDE THE MUSCLES
POSITIONS ARE NON SWORN CIVILIAN
POSITIONS THAT DEAL WITH
LICENSING.
YEAH WE DON'T HAVE ANY THAT
DON'T HAVE PEACE OFFICER POWERS.
TO DEAL WITH THAT STUFF SAID IN
THE DAYS IF YOU'RE GONNA GO AND
VIGOROUSLY ATTACK IT.
YOU STILL NEED SOMEBODY WITH A
BADGE AND A GUN. TO TO DEAL WITH
IT BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO THEY
CAN'T SEETHINGS THEY HAVE NO
POWER NO ENFORCEMENT POWERS
RIGHT AT ABOUT EIGHTY OF THOSE
WILL BE SOMEWHERE IN STAFF BUT
WE DO HEAR YOU ON YOUR COMMENTS
AND UNDERSTAND YOUR POSITION ON
IT.
AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER THING
TO POINT OUT IS THAT MOST OF THE
FUNDING PROVIDED TODAY FOR THE
CANNABIS ACTIVITIES HAS BEEN
LIMITED TERM.
SO THERE'S GONNA BE A LARGE
PROGRAM RIGHT SIZING AND THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS.
AND AND THERE MAY BE FUTURE
ADJUSTMENTS TO ENFORCEMENT --
RESOURCES AT THAT TIME.
OKAY -- GO OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT --
AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION -- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- AS WELL AS THE
COMMENTS BY -- MISTER LACKEY IN
MISTER NAZARIAN WE WOULD ECHO
THE CONCERNS THAT YOU'VE
EXPRESSED WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE LOCAL -- ENFORCEMENT GRANT
PROGRAM THAT'S BEING PROPOSED --
AND FUNDED AT TWENTY SIX MILLION --
WE DO BELIEVE THAT ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS ARE
NECESSARY -- WE WOULD CERTAINLY
REQUEST ADDITIONAL FUNDING --
FOR THE SAFETY ASSURANCE AND
FINANCIAL ENFORCEMENT UNIT --
UNDER THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING -- FOR OPERATOR
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WITHIN THE
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT UNIT WHICH
IS COVERED UNDER DCA SO -- THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT THE INDUSTRY
THIS YEAR HAS MADE THEIR TOP
PRIORITY -- ENFORCEMENT IS A
REAL CONCERN FOR THE COMPLAINT
INDUSTRY WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
WE DO APPRECIATE THE THIRTY NINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION THAT'S BEING
DIRECTED TO ADDRESS ILLICIT
CAMPUS CULTIVATION.
BUT WE WOULD ALSO EMPHASIZE THAT --
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
ILLICIT RETAIL OPERATORS IN
CALIFORNIA -- AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS DIRECTED
TOWARDS ILLICIT RETAIL WHICH WE
BELIEVE -- IS REALLY CAUSING A
pMARKET THAT JUST SIMPLY CAN'T
COMPETE WITH THOSE RETAILERS SO --
ENFORCEMENT IS A TOP PRIORITY
FOR US AND WE WOULD ASK FOR AN
ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION OF FUNDS
TO SUPPORT SWORN PEACE OFFICERS --
TO ADDRESS -- ILLICIT ACTIVITY
THE MORE IMPORTANTLY THAN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS IS THE INDUSTRY
GETTING BEHIND IN SAYING WE WANT
TO DO WITH THE BLACK MARKET.
AND THERE -- RETAILERS HAVE DONE
NOTHING THE MYSTERY IS DONE.
SQUAT IT'S BEEN SEVERAL BILLS
LAST YEAR THAT DEL THE BLACK
MARKET.
AND THEY WERE IN ABSENT SO.
FACTSET AYE AYE AYE BUT DRIVERS
WITH YOU GUYS IN CARE
LEGISLATION AND I'M JUST TIRED
OF YOU KNOW.
YOU GUYS IN ON YOUR HANDS.
ARE THE INDUSTRY I SHOULD SAY
NOT YOU.
IT BRIEFLY MISTER CHAIR -- JEFF
NEAL WITH THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
WHAT I THINK AB AND SUPPORT THE
LANGUAGE SURPRISE ADDITIONAL
CONTINUITY FOR THE LOCAL AND AND
STATE -- COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
LICENSING SYSTEM PARTICULAR THE
EXTENSION OF THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND THE
ELIMINATION OF THAT TWENTY
TWENTY SUNSET.
IN A LICENSES THANK YOU.
OKAY REAL THIS ITEM OPEN THAT
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING